Ok, ich bin noch ein bisschen früher, die ihr wahrscheinlich gemerkt habt, wobei es
noch keiner gemerkt hat, weil ich habe vor 5 Sekunden auf Start gedrückt, da ist noch
keiner da.
Lul.
So erstmal kurz gucken, ob das hier stimmt, natürlich wieder nett.
So.
Wow.
Wollte ich übertreiben?
Ich übertreibe.
Ah, ein bisschen Refresh und vielleicht gibt es da noch ein paar gescheite Sachen.
So, jetzt erstmal checken, bis das Stream on ist oder bis, ah ok, der erste, erste
wird schon da, hütsch.
Ne, ne, heut wird nichts gebrickt.
Oh, oh, ich habe China-Flaschen im Titel stehen.
Zack, das ist falsch, wir machen Aufwachen-Stream, Lul, äh, Moment, der Stream-Titel ist falsch,
der Stream-Titel ist falsch, äh, Moment.
So, jetzt müsste der Stream-Titel richtig sein, sag mal ja.
Ah ja, nice.
Jetzt ist der Stream-Titel richtig.
Excellent, exellente.
Ebolon, 22 Monate, danke für den Sub.
Massive, das Serious Max auch, 16 Monate am Start.
Gold Kicks Unlocked, wobei hat man ja schon mit einem Jahr.
Oh, BTF, warum habe ich so viele Abos, habe ich, Moment, ich habe irgendwie Subs übersehen.
Die letzten Streams kann das sein, ich glaube, ich habe einen neuen Abo-Rekord, aber es geht
auf Ende des Jahres, so lange geht es immer hoch.
Ja, vor drei Tagen haben brutal viele abonniert, vor drei Tagen war ich noch gar nicht on,
oder?
Vor drei Tagen, und, hä, warum haben vor drei Tagen so viele Leute abonniert?
Moment, vor drei Tagen, was war dann vor drei Tagen?
Max, hall die Klappe, das geht mir bei diesem neuen Twitch-Layout voll auf den Sack, dass
es automatisch anfängt.
Ah doch, hier, China-Geräte, vielleicht habe ich total viele Subs gekriegt, habe ich gar
nicht gesehen.
Oh, gut, ich meine, ich will mich jetzt ja nicht beschweren, oder?
Ja, ich dachte, es ist länger her, Scheiße, ja, wir lassen uns cheap baiten, bisschen kleiner
machen.
Das Video vom Bauer habe ich offen, der Auer, der Auer, Moment, wo ist er hier, äh, hier,
das gucken wir uns nachher an, ich habe es immer noch nicht fertig gemacht, aber es
gibt kein anderes Video, bis das kommt.
Ich muss heute noch ziemlich viel organisatorisch Zeug machen, was für Battlefield, da muss
ich endlich noch mal die Hetzner-Rechnung fertig machen, dass es Kohle gibt, ähm, dann
muss ich das Video mit der Endpunkt noch fertig machen.
Es macht eigentlich New Worlds so, ich habe gestern mal auf Twitter gefragt und die Leute
waren auch teilweise verhalten zuversichtlich, zeig mal, New World Stats, wie geht es denn
New World gerade so, Steam Stats, mal gucken, ob meine Prediction eintrifft, dass das bis
Februar, bis Februar die Leute gemerkt haben, dass sie es eigentlich gar nicht spielen
wollen.
Es geht schon, es geht schon ein bisschen runter, aber das sieht man hier noch gar nicht, keine
Ahnung hier, ach da, ach da, da war das Game noch nicht raus, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
man sieht, man sieht das schon, hier runter, guck mal, wir sind runter von Alltime Peak
zu die Hälfte, zu der Hälfte, na, wir haben schon mal die Hälfte der Spieler verloren,
na, das geht schon, aber das ist normal, das ist normal, das ist ja bei MMOs normal,
das ist quasi das erste paar Wochen, das Game ist ja auch erst irgendwie, das Game wirklich
erst drei Wochen raus, ok, für drei Wochen ist schon krass, ne, wurde zufällig vorgeschlagen
als, also es geht schon, es geht schon hart runter, wir sind hier von einem Peak von fast
einer Million, das ist auch ein Sonntag, das hier müsste auch ein, das ist ein Sonntag
gewesen, ok, gucken wir heute mal, gucken wir heute mal, aber, guck mal, letzten Sonntag,
letzten Sonntag waren es bloß noch 7000, dann sind es heute wahrscheinlich, guck mal, letzten
Sonntag waren es 700, davor waren es 600, 67, das heißt in ungefähr, dann wären das
heute wahrscheinlich 610.000, so ungefähr sein, Massive Stonks Prediction, sag euch,
im Februar, im Februar reden wir drüber, im Februar sind dann wirklich bloß noch die
Leute übrig, denen das Kern-Gameplay, und da gibt es aber New World nicht so viel, noch
gefällt, spätestens wenn die Streamer alle weg sind und die ganzen Streamer-Fanboys da
keinen Bock mehr drauf haben, weil ihr Lieblingsstreamer jetzt was anderes spielt, dann landen wir
wahrscheinlich auf ein paar Servern mit gutem Spiel, mit guten Spielerzahlen, ich kann mir
schon vorstellen, dass New World sich langfristig hält, aber natürlich nicht in diesen Regionen,
New World hält sich höchstens in den Regionen, die halt auf diese Faction-Based-PvP-Sachen
stehen, und selbst das, was ich bisher davon gesehen habe, wirkte das auf mich doch etwas
stumpf, wieso so früh wach und dann noch gar nicht ausgeschlafen, ich bin seit 8 schon
wach, jetzt nach 8, Max wie gehts, ja ich müsste mal das Video mit der Endpunkt fertig
machen, dann könntest du ein Video hochladen, dann wirds mir auch wieder gut gehen, und
ich muss organisatorische Sachen erledigen, ihr wisst das, ich schieb Sachen immer, auf
die ich keinen Bock hab, also jetzt nicht das Video machen, alles andere, immer weit
raus, und irgendwann denkst du dir, jetzt musst du es aber echt mal machen, ich glaub
das Problem hat nicht, hab nicht nur ich, ja und, was wollt ich jetzt sagen, wisst ihr
was ich noch witzig finde zu New World, möchte jetzt nicht zu sehr über ein Game ablästern,
was ich kann, ich wirklich spiele, aber was ich noch witzig finde ist, die Leute haben
sich jahrelang, ich ja auch, über MMOs beschwert, Dezember Urlaub, ja ich bin sogar vor Dezember
schon daheim komplett, wahrscheinlich ab Ende November, weil ich hab noch urlaub übrig,
zeig ich dir das einfach davor, ergibt man hier keine Provision, doch doch, ich krieg
wenn ich was mache, und das ist nicht so oft, ich krieg aber keinen festen monatlichen Betrag,
dann müsste ich mich ja festlegen auf monatliche, monatliche Sachen, so, ja was ich persönlich
auch ganz lustig an New World finde ist, und ich hab mich ja auch jahrelang drüber beschwert,
dass viele moderne MMOs einfach nicht mehr so sind, wie ich mir das wünsche, ein MMO
sollte halt diesen Massive Online Fokus haben, also sprich nicht Solo Questen, Solo Dungeons
und alles mögliche, aber in die Richtung ging es halt, so und da hab ich mich drüber
beschwert, so und das ist ja New World explizit nicht, New World ist deutlich oldschooliger
als manch andere MMOs, die können sich nicht entscheiden, die können sich mit dem Musiklaut
nicht entscheiden, haben wir hier vielleicht, jawoll, so also, jetzt, ja New World ist ja
deutlich oldschooliger als andere MMOs, aber was ich halt witzig finde, guckt mal bei
reddit auf New World, die Leute sind teilweise jetzt schon dabei und wollen einen Dungeon
Finder haben, das ist so hängen geblieben, warum wollen die Leute in einem Game, was
explizit nicht quasi ein modernes Solo MMO sein möchte, den Nummer 1 Grund, warum MMOs
zu Solo Spielen geworden sind, einbauen, kann mir das irgendjemand sinnvoll erklären,
ich spiel das nicht, aber einen Dungeon Finder einzubauen ist so komplett anti der Idee von
New World, dass es feste Server gibt mit einer beschränkten Spieleranzahl, dass Spielerinteraktion
quasi hochgehalten wird und auch ein bisschen mehr auf player driven Events und sowas eingegangen
wird, ansprich wann gibt es wo irgendwie eine PvP Schlacht oder sonst was, warum um alles
in der Welt will man da einen Dungeon Finder einbauen, das verstehe ich nicht, es ist also
so, das kann ich absolut nicht verstehen, guckt euch an, das ist ja nicht die einzige, das
ist der Wahnsinn, ich verstehe es nicht, was man machen könnte ist, was man machen könnte
ist ein Group Finder, das finde ich ja auch in Ordnung, Group Finder ist ja ok, dass
man sich flaggt als Looking for Group, da muss man angeschrieben werden, invadet werden
zur Instanz laufen und sonst wie was, dann mögen die Leute das Game nicht, das Spiel
ist designt als nicht Solo MMO, die Leute mögen vielleicht einzelne Elemente, die fällen
gerne Bäume oder sowas, die mögen einzelne Elemente, aber der Grundgedanke bei New World
und das ist ja eigentlich was, was mich ansprechen müsste, aber das Gamer sich spricht mich
nicht an, dass es eben wirklich mal wieder ein MMO im klassischen MMO Sinn ist, also
Massively Multiplayer, dass es Interaktion zwischen Leuten gibt und dass es eben zum
größten Teil ein Server aus, wie soll ich sagen, No Names ist, aber feste No Names
und ein paar bekannter Leute, die sich das aber halt auch über die Zeit erarbeitet haben,
wahrscheinlich weil sie 24-7 Hardcore sind, keine Ahnung, so wie das halt in MMOs nun
mal so ist, aber ich verstehe es nicht, wie man da einen Dungeon Fighter haben wollen
kann, das verstößt komplett gegen die Idee des Games, ja ich spiele es nicht, ich spiele
es nicht, warum ich es nicht spiele, kann man ganz einfach zusammenfassen, ich habe
mir ja die Beta angeguckt, auch News Berichterstattung und ich habe noch am Anfang, als es in Entwicklung
war, gesagt, ja New World ist alles der wenige MMO, den ich zutraue, dass ich mich da mal
wieder für interessieren könnte, aber nachdem ja New World mittlerweile so ein billiges
identitätsloses Game geworden ist, zumindest fühlt sich das für mich so an, habe ich da
keinen Bock, so, wie findest du die neue Beta von Windows 11, habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert,
kenne ich nicht, Lucky Luke, danke schön für den Sub, Angel, danke für den Sub, gar
nicht gesehen, ne, der hat schon mit mir aufgenommen, was soll er denn so, kann er schlecht seine
eigene Audio Spur schneiden, am Letzten von Twitch hat er einen 1hE Server gebaut, da
ist GG Eats, und hast du was kaputt gemacht, oder wie hat es funktioniert, hast du was gebrauchtes
gekauft oder, wahrscheinlich gehe ich mal, du hast wahrscheinlich irgendwas gebrauchtes
gekauft und dann abgestückt, gibt es ja bei Ebay relativ viel, ist eigentlich gar keine
so schlechte Idee, so, also, welche Chrome Addons benutzt du eigentlich, so gut wie keine,
ich habe hier Uplog, das braucht man, ohne Uplog kannst du nicht mehr ins Internet, Dark
Reader, Dark Reader ist hier für sowas, Flashbang, FFZ, natürlich, was sonst, und hier Volume
Regeln für die Webseite, das war's, mehr habe ich nicht, mehr habe ich glaube ich
auch bei meinem eigentlichen Browser, den ich normalerweise so benutze nicht, alles klappt
außer die beiden, ah, wenn das ein Dual, also ein Board mit zwei Sockets ist, dann ist es
bestimmt was älteres, komm, wir gucken jetzt mal bei ihm, was ein Server, den er gebaut
hat, vielleicht war das auch nur billige Eigenwerbung, das es im Chat geschrieben hat, aber das interessiert
mich jetzt, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an, so, hier, wo ist der Server, da, Science and
Technology, hier wird der Server gebaut, exellent, zeig mal her, oh, ein bisschen mehr Licht
wäre glaube ich gut gewesen, ah, Dual Socket, ok, Dual Socket, dann ist es bestimmt ein
bisschen was älteres, oder, ist das ein altes IBM Case, ah, jetzt hat er Licht, ok, exellent,
das ist bestimmt gebraucht, oder, ah, das ist ein bisschen älter, ja, das sieht man
auch schon hier, also den Rack, wo du das einbaust, weil das sieht mir schon aus wie
normale Bautiefe, also so 70cm oder so, und 70cm Rack musst du auch erstmal haben und
irgendwo hinbekommen, ja, sowas könnte man eigentlich auch mal im Stream machen, da kaufe
ich mir auf Ebay irgendeinen Billigenserver, wir basteln ein bisschen dran rum, jetzt,
guck mal, wie ist das so ein FF, FF Server, ne, das machen wir nicht, weil es total verschenktes
Geld ist, yeah, 14€, Bäm, das sieht von den Farben her aus wie ein alter HP oder Dell,
die kann ich teilweise nicht aushalten, aber wahrscheinlich eher alter HP, also rein von
den Cages hier, von den Disk Drive, ne, das ist tatsächlich ganz gutes Preis-Leistungsverhältnis,
die alten HP Dinger, naja, egal, wie dem auch sei, ah, nice, ja, ich hab mein Rack ja mittlerweile
ein bisschen abgespeckt, wofür sind denn so welche Server für die Eilungslosen, du kannst
mit den Dingern genau das gleiche machen, wie du mit einem stinknormalen Desktop-PC auch
machst, also Hardware-technisch, also der Software ist das egal, worauf die läuft, ob
die auf einer Server-Kiste läuft oder ob die auf einem Desktop-PC läuft, gut, ich meine,
Spiele kannst du damit dank fehlender Grafikkarte nicht machen, ne, das ist auch nicht Sinn
und Zweck der Sache, warum man das kauft, ist erstens mal die Bauform, weil du die in
den Rack einbauen kannst, 19-Zoll-Rack, also sowas, steht im Rechenzentrum, gibt's aber
auch kleinere Varianten, also solche Dinger, so Schränke, gibt aber auch kleinere, das
ist jetzt hier für Netzwerkgeräte, Audio-Equipment hat auch 19-Zoll-Racks, ja, wenn du sowas hast,
halt im Rechenzentrum stehen, da passt die Bauform halt ganz gut, weil da kannst du
die Dinger bis zur Decke stapeln und hast Schienen, wo du sie rausziehen kannst dran,
das ist halt vom Handling her einfacher, als da irgendwelche Gehäuse, Tower hinzustellen
und ansonsten, ja ja gut, oftmals ist es halt so, dass Server-Hardware und Bauweisen
ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, relundanter ausgelegt sind, oftmals hast du zwei Netzteile,
wo eins kaputt gehen kann, gut, in dem Fall hier nicht, nehmen wir mal beispielsweise,
DELL NHP GL380, so, die neuen sehen ja übrigens richtig futuristisch aus, ne, da hast du
teilweise hier mehrere Netzteile, im Fall sieht's gar nicht so aus, aber kann durchaus
sein, mehrere Netzteile und du hast halt auch die Kühlung entsprechend, dass du die hier
in so einem Server-Rack, wo du dann mehrere nebeneinander stehen hast, gut unterbringen
kannst, das ist dann meistens so, entweder ist innen warm oder außen kalt oder außen
kalt und innen warm, aber meistens ist es so, dass innen das von der Klimaanlage abgesaugt
wird, also du stellst dann die Racks quasi so zusammen und innen saugst dann halt quasi
die warme Luft, die die Server pusten raus, das passt halt einfach besser von der Bauweise
her ins Rechenzentrum, ansonsten, für dich ist es letztendlich egal, also sagen wir mal,
du willst irgendwie ne Minecraft-Server bei dir daheim laufen lassen, lass den ruhig
auf deinem Desktoprechner laufen, das hat überhaupt, oder auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen
oder sonst wie, das gucken wir uns gleich an, das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn sich dafür
irgendwie großartige Server-Hardware zu kaufen, ein Vorteil von Server-Hardware ist oftmals
auch noch, dass es länger Ersatzteile gibt und dass du meistens zumindest, jetzt bei
den bisschen teureren, bei denen hier ist es auf jeden Fall der Fall, dass du im laufenden
Betrieb Teile tauschen kannst, also du kannst zum Beispiel, wir haben ja mal ein gutes Bild
von, also so wie ich die Hetzner-Hardware kenne, ich weiß nicht was sie gezeigt haben,
haben die relativ viel Desktop-Hardware, außer bei den Dedicated-Servern, das glaube ich
nicht so gut zum zeigen, aber wir gucken uns das gleich an, ja hier siehst du das
eigentlich ganz gut, man sieht, dass es hier relativ modular ist, also du kannst hier recht
viel tauschen und das sogar während die Kiste läuft, ja alte Server fressen Strom, also
empfehlen würde ich das tatsächlich nicht, ja guck, du kannst die Lüfter tauschen hier
einzeln, du kannst die Netzteile tauschen, dadurch, dass du zwei Netzteile hast, ich
gehe mal davon aus, hier stecken zwei Netzteile drin, wenn du zwei Netzteile hast, kannst
du sogar eins was kaputt ist tauschen im laufenden Betrieb und sowas, das ist halt eher dafür
ausgelegt und da kommt einem halt die Bauweise zugute, du ziehst das hier vorne aus dem
Rack raus, machst die Klappe oben auf und kommst dann halt hier so direkt dran, was
du bei einem Tower aufgrund der Bauweise ja gar nicht hast, ja, das sind eigentlich so
die Vorteile, ja Nachteile für den Heimbereich sind relativ offensichtlich an der Chat auch
schon, achso ja, das habe ich gar nicht daran gedacht, stimmt, ja, du hast bei quasi allen
auch Einsteiger, also da musst du schon wirklich ultra billig kaufen, wenn du das nirgendwo
hast, du hast bei den ganzen fertigen Servern, die du kaufst von der Hersteller hast du auch
Remote-Management dabei, also du kannst dich auf dem Server einloggen, kann ich dir zeigen,
das siehst du auch direkt immer hinten an den Interfaces, dass du noch zweite Netzwerkkarte
nur fürs Management drin hast, Baseboard, ne wie heißt der Kram, Moment, warte mal,
iDRAC ist bei Dell, ILO ist bei HP ne und RS A2 ist bei IBM, glaub so war das, zumindest
du hast, du hast hier, ich weiß, frag mich jetzt nicht welche, das ist wahrscheinlich
die hier, du hast hier ein extra Management-Interface, das geht direkt aufs Mainboard mit einem extra
Controller drauf, da kannst du dann auch aufs BIOS und so was drüber zugreifen, da loggst
du dich ein mit einem Webbrowser, früher waren die Dinger ganz gerne mal Java basiert
oder Flash basiert, ich weiß, ich erinnere mich von euch noch einer an die Zeit, wo du
teilweise Flash-Ilos und Flash-RL und Java Remote-Management Sachen hattest, das war
richtig, richtiger Paints-Champ, oftmals nur unter Windows im Internet Explorer lauffähig,
ganz, ganz grausam, zumindest mittlerweile haben sie es geschafft bei den halbwegs neuen,
also so alles sag mal innerhalb der letzten 5 Jahre sind die Web-Interfaces meistens HTML5,
ja hier sieht man es gar nicht, ich vermute mal das hier ist der Management-Port, aber
kann jetzt, kann alles Mögliche sein, achja übrigens eine Sache, die hier auch immer wieder
dabei so einfach sieht ist VGA Anschluss, also HDMI und Display-Port haben es eigentlich
so gut wie noch gar nicht ins Rechenzentrum geschafft, es gibt mittlerweile, glaube die
ganz neuen haben auch tatsächlich sowas wie ein HDMI oder Display-Port teilweise, aber
in der Regel haben die eigentlich alle VGA, VGA, VGA, aber du schließt dich da eh nie
dran an, von denen habe ich einen KVM, IP-KVM, der hat auch auch Java, naja manchmal brauchst
du schon grafische Oberfläche, gerade wenn du Windows auf dem Server hast, was willst
du machen, ja, also VGA ist da vollkommen normal und meistens geht man da auch gar nicht
direkt ran, sondern greift hier übers Netzwerk über den Management-Port, so hier Dedicated
ELO-Port, da ist es doch, meistens greift man mit Management, aber manchmal, also in
meiner Zeit, wo ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, da wo ich noch oftmals Turnschuh-Admin
Jobs ausführen musste, also so 2010 rum, nee 2007 rum, da ist man dann manchmal mit
dem Wagen durchs Rechenzentrum gefahren, da hattest du so einen Wagen mit Monitor und
Tastatur drauf und verschiedenen Adaptern und da bist du wirklich, also wenn die Kiste
gar nichts mehr gemacht hat, dann bist du wirklich hinten an den Server ran gefahren,
hast dich angestöpselt per USB, man hatte schon USB oder PS2, PS2, es gibt heute übrigens
immer noch bei Servern relativ viel PS2 und wenn nicht, gibt es teilweise auch genug Tastaturen,
die im Rechenzentrum rumstehen, die sind PS2, naja, zumindest, da bist du mit dem Wagen
hingefahren, hast dich angestöpselt mit VGA und USB-Tastatur oder PS2 und hast dann erstmal
gehofft, dass du das Ding wiederbeleben kannst, okay, sieht man doch, hier sind zwei Netzteile
drin, klappst du hier hinten runter und flupp, ziehst du raus, PS5 ist besser, richtiger
Pace Champions, aber gar nicht, der ist gar nicht schlecht, ja gut, haben wir uns jetzt
genug angeguckt, ja würde ich sagen, wenn wir doch gerade dabei sind, komm, da gucken
wir uns jetzt das Video vom Bauer an, der Auer, wo ist er, Kokona-Video hier, nee, da
hier, in diesem Gebäude stehen 200.000 Server, zu Besuch bei Hetzner in Faltenstein, in Faltenstein
ist er nicht in Nuremberg oder nicht in Helsinki, warte mal, chat, hallo Wuppenburser, ja, so
sieht es aus, sag mal, was hältst du von der derzeitigen Situation, einen PC, gar nichts,
ich möchte mir schon seit über 1, wenn nicht sogar fast, ja lange, lange, auf jeden Fall
schon seit einem Jahr einen neuen Rechner bauen, man darf nicht vergessen, mein Rechner
ist 4 Jahre alt, guck mal, mein Rechner ist fast genau 4 Jahre alt, das muss man sich
mal vorstellen, auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, ich habe einen 4 Jahre alten Rechner und kann
mit dem alles spielen in gutem Detail, das ist der Wahnsinn, das hätt es früher nicht
gegeben Leute, da war nach eineinhalb Jahren Schluss, so, ja, ich halte da nichts davon,
ich sehe das nämlich nicht ein, für eine Grafikkarte 1200 Euro zu bezahlen und auch
sonst nicht das zu bekommen, was ich will und außerdem der nächste Grund, warum ich
mir jetzt keinen neuen Rechner bauen will ist, ich hätte mir schon vor über einem Jahr
das kaufen können, was ich mir jetzt kaufe, also es hat sich da auch in der Zeit nichts
getan, also ich werde wahrscheinlich eher auf die nächste Generation warten und bis
das ganze wieder erhältlich ist und tja, auch wenn es noch ein bisschen dauern wird, hey,
ich komme mit meinem übertragten 8700k mit 1080ti bisher echt ohne Probleme hin, ihr wisst,
ich lege eh mehr Wert drauf, auf niedrige Details und mehr FPS als hohe Details, klar
bei Singleplayer-Spielen mag es ein bisschen anders aussehen, was ich spiele ist meistens
eh nicht sonderlich anspruchsvoll, ist immer Battlefield und so außen vor, aber selbst
Battlefield in niedrigen Details wird bei Release denke ich mal ganz brauchbar laufen,
wir können das ja nicht alles jetzt ja auf, also das sind Sachen, die würde ich wirklich
nicht auf die Beta schieben, es gibt viele Sachen, die kannst du auf die Beta schieben,
aber das nicht, ich denke das wird ganz brauchbar laufen und ansonsten spiele ich das aktuelle
Pathfinder-Game, das braucht nicht sonderlich viel, ansonsten hält sich das ein bisschen
in Grenzen, ja, also ich baue mir erst wieder einen neuen PC, ich baue mir erst wieder
einen neuen PC, wenn es eine neue Generation gibt, sowohl von Nvidia als auch von AMD,
ich will mir nämlich unbedingt wieder einen AMD Rechner bauen, es kann natürlich sein,
möglich ist es, dass wenn ich mir dann in einem Jahr oder zwei oder wann auch immer
es wieder halbwegs Hardware gibt, der nächste Generation, dass dann Intel wieder besser
ist, dann kaufe ich mir Intel, ich hätte mir gerne mal wieder ein AMD PC gekauft, aber
mein Scheiß drauf, ich sage das ja oft genug, es hat ja echt keinen Sinn da irgendwie zu
Fanboyen, die werden ein nie, das ist genauso wie die Leute, die die DICE Super Fanboyen
und sowas, die werden nie irgendwie die Wahl zum Super Fanboy machen und du kriegst dann
irgendwie irgendwas dafür, umso mehr Fanboy umso mehr ist man eigentlich nur gefundenes
Fressen für die Hersteller, das ist alles, also zu Fanboyen ist echt blöd, natürlich
gibt es auch Sachen, die ich geil finde, keine Frage, ist ja keiner gewappnet dagegen, aber
trotzdem, einfach blind zu Fanboyen ist eigentlich das blödeste, was man machen kann, ja sehe
ich auch nicht ein, guckst du morgen das Apple Event, ja wahrscheinlich, aber nicht im Stream,
ihr wisst was letztes Mal im Stream passiert ist, als wir Tim Apple zugeguckt haben, ich
habe den Strike immer noch, gucken ob der irgendwann weggeht, hey ich schaue deine Videos
auf YouTube an, exellent, bald gibt es wieder Neues, 800 Viewer Stream, ja das stimmt, da
haben relativ viele geguckt, oh da waren auch ein paar Apple Fanboys da, die haben sich
voll beschwert darüber, dass ich nicht alles geil fand, das weiß ich noch, da kann ich
mich noch dran erinnern, geht das mal nicht so schlecht, das ist doch alles ganz toll,
die wissen schon was sie machen, Leute ihr wollt nicht, dass ich neue Strikes bekomme,
wenn ich noch ein paar Strikes bekomme ist der Channel weg, es sei denn ihr guckt den
Stream nicht gerne und seid nur hier, dass ihr sehen wollt, wenn ich es mal verkacke
um mich zu reporten, gibt es ja auch immer, also ich würde mal sagen so eine Einstellige
Prozentzahl der Leute gucken Streamer hauptsächlich nicht weil sie ihn mögen oder den Content
gerne gucken, sondern weil sie ihn hassen und mitbekommen wollen, wenn er es verkackt
um ihn dann zu reporten, ich weiß wilde Theorie aber haltet ihr es für so abwegig, alter,
alter Lake, ja Intel sagt viel wenn der Tag lang ist, mal gucken wie es dann wirklich
so ist, ist zurzeit also preisleistungsmäßig und das was du dafür bekommst ist AMD schon
seit 2-3 Jahren, zumindest vorne mit dabei, man kann nicht sagen, dass das im Prinzip
überall besser ist, gerade wenn man wirklich auf das letzte FPS in Games guckt, dann ist
es oftmals tatsächlich immer noch sinnvoller Intel zu kaufen, allerdings bekommt man bei
AMD in der Regel mehr Kerne für weniger Geld, also insgesamt hast du meistens den besseren
Deal bei AMD, aber ja Gaming Performance ist Intel oftmals immer noch ein paar kleine kleine
Punkte vorne. Was sagst du zu Battlefield Portal, wird gut oder einfach nur Geld machen?
Tja das weiß ich nicht, da bin ich mal gespannt, ich mein es ist ja im Prinzip ein Battlefield
2042 mit den Assets aus Battlefield 3, BC2 und was war das dritte, 1942? Ich weiß gar
nicht, also es wird sich dann nicht spielen wie BC2 oder wie BF3, es wird sich dann spielen
wie Battlefield 2042 halt mit alten Assets. Ja, hatte ich mir angeschaut, hat aber keine
Web RTC Unterstützung, das heißt die Kameras hatten Delay, das hat mir nicht gefallen.
Vielleicht haben sie das mittlerweile, kann sein. Ja, bald ist es soweit. Bald bedeutet,
ich hab mir eigentlich vor, also ich sag das ja schon ewig, aber ich hab schon angefangen
ja dran rum zu wurschteln und ich hab nicht weiter gemacht, ich hab gestern auch nichts
gemacht, also ich hoffe ich krieg das heute hin. Wir haben halt 40 Minuten geschwätzt
und ich muss daraus irgendwie 20 Minuten Video machen. Ihr wisst doch meine Zeitangaben sind
immer äußerst verlässlich. Hab ich schon einmal falsche Zeitangaben gemacht? Kann
ich mich nicht dran erinnern. Nee, ich kann nicht alles hochladen, da sind paar Names
gedroppt zwischendurch, das muss ich rausschneiden. Ok, kommen wir uns mal das Video vom Bauer
an. In Nuremberg, nee, in Falkenstein, wo wir gerade dabei sind. Ausrufezeichen Hetzner
im Chat, wenn ihr euch 20€ Startgut haben für die Hetzner Cloud sichern wollt, wenn
ihr euren eigenen virtuellen Linux Server haben wollt oder mal ein bisschen basteln
möchtet, mittlerweile auch mit eingebauten Firewalls, dass keiner auf eure Server zugreifen
kann, dann könnt ihr euch mit meinem Code bis Ende des Jahres registrieren und bekommt
20€ Startgut haben. So und jetzt gucken wir uns das Video vom Bauer an. Oder was war
das ja, was hältst du von der, so neu ist die gar nicht, die gibt es schon seit 2010
oder so. Hat sich aber nie so wirklich durchgesetzt, außer jetzt bei den, oder nicht mal da großartig,
bei den im Science Bereich. Oh, da gibt es ganz viele, irgendwas individuelles was dich
interessiert. Nee, das bin ich nicht. Ich sag ich komm gleich gucken und komm nie vorbei.
Warum soll ich am nächsten Morgen kommen? Ich hoffe am nächsten Morgen hat es derjenige
vergessen von gestern oder schon jemand anderes gefunden. Was soll ich überhaupt vorbeikommen?
So, also jetzt gucken wir uns das Video vom Bauer an. 23 Minuten Hetzner Stels.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video. Wir sind heute in Falkenstein,
im Vogtland, also im Osten von Deutschland. Hinter mir, vielleicht erkennst du die Annalade
von unseren Werbespots. Wir sind heute bei unserem Kooperationspartner Hetzner. Wir
machen ja ganz viel Werbung für Hetzner. Hetzner ist ein Serverbetreiber in Deutschland.
Ich denke, das ist auch eins der größten Datacentren in Deutschland. Das werden wir
mit Sicherheit auch alles erfahren. Also von der Fläche her ist das tatsächlich,
also wenn ich das hier so hinten sehe, ist das tatsächlich relativ groß, wenn das alles
dazu gehört? So, mal gucken. Falkenstein, eigentlich nur so aus den guten alten Teamspeak-Zeiten
und früher, als man so Spiele-Server ausgewählt hat. Ich muss das doch ein bisschen lauter
machen. Wenn man dann die Location gesehen hat von den Servern, dann stand oft Falkenstein
dran. Ich hab mir da nie was bei gedacht. Ja, jetzt weiß ich was das ist. Lustigerweise
bauen die an. Wobei man halt sagen muss, das scheint nur ein Stockwerk zu sein. Die meisten,
zumindest in Frankfurt, Rechenzentren, die ich kenne, die sind meistens mehrstockig
und auch meistens noch mit Keller. Gerade der Dezix, das ist ja auch relativ groß das
Ding. Das ist mehrere Standorte und im Keller halt. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das Ganze
hier aussieht. Vor allem finde ich das sehr interessant unter dem Aspekt, dass Hetzner
teilweise auch Consumer Hardware für Server verwendet. Das kennt ihr vielleicht auch aus
den Werbespots. Ja, gut. Irgendwie musst du es ja machen, dass es günstig ist. Und
wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, ist es vollkommen egal, ob das Server Hardware ist oder Desktop
Hardware für dich als Anwender. Wenn du bezahlst für x, y und solange das funktioniert, kannst
dir eigentlich egal sein, worauf das läuft, weil Feature-mäßig ist es jetzt nicht so,
als würdest du einen großen Unterschied machen. Für dich ist der Dezix ein Rechenzentrum,
was denn sonst? Okay, ich weiß, du willst sagen, das ist ein Exchange-Point, aber natürlich
ist es ein Rechenzentrum. AMD Ryzen Desktop CPUs quasi für Server und ich erhoffe mir
da so ein paar Einblicke, was die dazu sagen, wenn man sowas langzeittechnisch benutzt, richtig
krass auslastet, wird mit Sicherheit relativ interessant. Ich würde sagen, wir gehen rein
und schauen uns das Ganze mal an. Auf geht's. Ist laut genug? Ich glaube schon. Ich bin
vor allem auch gespannt, wie Hetzner das Ganze macht, was das Thema In-Belt betrifft. Außerdem,
wie kann das überhaupt sein, dass sie Rechenzentren brauchen? Ich denke, heute ist alles serverless.
Könnte das vielleicht sein, dass man für serverless doch noch Server braucht? Trifft
und Energiemanagement, Kühlung und so weiter. Könnte das sein, dass serverless einfach
nur ein doofes Buzzword ist? Alles möglich. Mit dem Klimawandel denke ich mal sehr interessant
und Hetzner sagt ja auch, die sind da sehr verantwortungsvoll. Da bin ich wirklich sehr
gespannt, was mir auf jeden Fall auffällt. Überall alles voller Stacheldraht. Scheint
mir gut gesichert zu sein. Na Benzel, Dankeschön für den Sub. Geh mal rein. Ich bin gespannt.
Das hat schon ein bisschen sowas vom Gefängnis mit diesem Riesentor, mit dem Stacheldraht
obendrauf. Krass, krass. Die wenigsten Leute brauchen LCC-RAM. Wann brauchst du schon
mal LCC-RAM, wenn du dir was zum hausten in der Cloud kaufst, ob da LCC-RAM drin ist
oder nicht, ist doch eigentlich... Vielleicht wenn du irgendwie ein ZFS oder... Ja, selbst
dann ist drauf. Neben dem Standort hier in Falkenstein, den wir heute besuchen, hat Hetzner
übrigens noch einen weiteren in Nürnberg, also etwas südlicher in Deutschland und noch
einen weiteren in Helsinki, in Finnland. Was ich persönlich sehr interessant finde,
ist, dass Hetzner dabei... In Finnland, in Finnland ist angeblich 100% erneuerbare Energien
für Strom. Vielleicht auch mittlerweile in Deutschland, aber in Finnland auf jeden Fall
schon eine Weile. Man verachtet, dass 100% Ökostrom verwendet wird in Deutschland. Ah
ja, passt ja. Und in Finnland können Sie sogar sicherstellen, dass der gesamte Strombedarf
mit Windkraft nur aufgesorgt wird. Okay, ich muss gar nichts sagen. Das ist das, was wir
in der Übersicht gerade beim Intro ganz links quasi gesehen haben. Das Gebäude wurde 2008
gebaut, das ist das erste. Und Hetzner hat über die Jahre immer hochskaliert. Sieht
ein bisschen aus wie ein Aldi, wie so ein Aldi-Gebäude oder so ein Lidl irgendwie. Und ich bin sehr
gespannt, wir gehen jetzt mal rein und schauen uns... Nee, eher... Nee, eher wie das, was
einer im Chat kriegt, wie so ein Bauhaus. Ja, stimmt schon. 250.000 Servern, die da drin
stehen an. Also das ist schon ordentlich viel. So, wir sind jetzt im, wie gesagt, ersten
Rechenzentrum. Das ist ja 2008 gebaut, dementsprechend auch ein bisschen älter, dementsprechend
sind auch die Server ein bisschen älter. Wir zeigen jetzt euch nur, damit man auch so
ein bisschen die Entwicklung nachvollziehen kann, was hier über die letzten Jahre passiert
ist. Ich finde es einfach schon richtig krass, man kommt rein und das sind einfach alles
Midi-Tower, die hier stehen. Wie gesagt, das sind so die ganz ersten Server. Warum nicht?
Die haben die eben immer noch, weil die sagen, ey, die funktionieren noch. Das sind wahrscheinlich
die, das sind wahrscheinlich die, die dir teilweise bei der Serverauktion mieten kannst
für 20 Euro. Wegwerfen, das wäre ja auch Ressourcenverschwendung, deswegen benutzt
man die einfach so lange weiter, wie die laufen, wie es noch Kunden gibt, die die verwenden
und bezahlen können. Wir schauen einfach mal rein, was da so drauf ist, also wenn wir
jetzt mal hier schauen zum Beispiel auf das Schild, dann könnt ihr hier sehen, da ist
ein i7-930 da. Das ist schon ein bisschen älter. X58, dementsprechend schon ein paar Jahre
älter. Und das ist auch wirklich wild gewürfelt. Wenn wir jetzt einfach mal eins rechts daneben
gehen, dann ist ja schon ein i7-6700 drin. Das ist ja dann schon ein paar Generationen
neuer. Ist das normal, dass die einfach per Mehrfachsteckdose angeschlossen sind? Wo
siehst du das? Also normal hast du an der Seite von den Racks so eine Stromleiste. Allerdings,
das hier sind ja gar keine klassischen Racks, das sind eher Supermarktregale. Hier. Das
ist so ein Typ, das ist eigentlich, bisschen lauter, ja, mach ich. Das ist eher so ein
Custom-Aufbau. Ich glaube, das ist einfach auch der Sache geschuldet, dass Hetzener halt
einer der günstigsten Server-Anbieter ist.
Das sind ja im Prinzip quasi Supermarktregale mit hier irgendwie dran montierten Mehrfachsteckdosen.
Nein, so sieht das normalerweise nicht aus. Aber das werden wir wahrscheinlich später
sehen, dass es bei denen halt auch an anderen Bereichen anders aussieht. Das ist wahrscheinlich
einfach der Sache geschuldet, dass es möglichst günstig sein soll. Sprich da überhaupt nichts
dagegen. Eigentlich ist es keine blöde Sache, das so zu machen.
Was da so drauf ist, dass wenn wir jetzt mal hier schauen zum Beispiel auf das Schild,
da könnt ihr sehen, da ist ein i7-930 drin. Also das ist ja x58, dementsprechend schon
ein paar Jahre älter. Und das ist auch ganz witzig, das ist auch wirklich wild gewürfelt.
Wenn wir jetzt einfach mal eins rechts daneben gehen, dann ist hier schon ein i7-6700 drin.
Das ist ja dann schon ein paar Generationen neuer.
Ja und noch eins weiter ist wahrscheinlich was ganz anderes drin.
Und neben dran ist zum Beispiel ein i7-930-30k, dann mit unterschiedlichen Konfigurationen,
was dann Board betrifft, RAM und so weiter. Also wirklich, wirklich krass. Das Ganze hat
sich über die Jahre natürlich krass verändert. Also Hetzner baut ja mittlerweile ganz eigene
Server-Schränke, die sind weg von den Midi-Towern und auch das Kühlkonzept ist übrigens sehr
interessant, denn wir stehen quasi auf der Kühlung. Also unter mir im Boden, quasi nochmal
ein Meter nach unten, da verlaufen Luftschächte und die gehen dann zur Seite und zwischen den
PCs, also da stehen immer zwei PC rein, die überstehen quasi mit der Front. Und an der
Front kann dann die kalte Luft angesaugt werden, dass quasi man hier so durchschauen würde
und die Lüftungskanäle laufen eben durch den Boden, gehen an den Boden.
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee. Das hast du, so oder so ähnlich, hast du das normalerweise
auch in, normalerweise Brechenzentrum gebaut, nur dass du es halt oftmals geschlossen hast.
Also du hast hier oben zu, du hast hier vorne noch eine Tür da ungefähr, wo er jetzt steht,
hier so vorne, hast du noch eine Tür und du hast da halt so, die saugen die Luft ein
und hier ist halt, da wo er steht, ist normalerweise dann quasi das, wo die warme Luft rausgepustet
wird und die Klimaanlage das nach oben absaugt. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch dem Aufbau
geschuldet.
An der Seite hoch und dann können die PCs die kalte Luft ansaugen.
Trotzdem einen Pulli an, brauchst du auch, brauchst du auch. Das würde ich euch auch
empfehlen, auch wenn es euch so vorkommt, dass ihr im Rechenzentrum immer ohne Probleme
im T-Shirt stehen könnt. Mittlerweile auf jeden Fall. Der Trend in Rechenzentren geht
eindeutig dahin, dass man es wärmer macht als früher. Also früher hattest du teilweise
18 Grad, wenn du da reingekommen bist. Heute ist es eigentlich normal, dass du 23, 24 Grad
hast. Das macht der Hardware nicht so viel aus und es spart halt unglaublich Kühlkosten.
Aber was du halt im Rechenzentrum immer noch hast, ist du hast, wenn du da durchläufst,
immer wieder den Wechsel zwischen relativ kalt, also von der Klimaanlage und relativ
warm und wenn du da durchläufst, du läufst permanent durch irgendwelche verschiedenen
Klimazonen quasi durch. Also einen Pulli, am besten so wie er das hat, das ist tatsächlich
gar nicht so blöd, da kannst du nämlich die Ärmel hochschieben. Das finde ich ist
die beste Kombination. Einen Pulli, wo du einfach die Ärmel hochschieben kannst. Also
ich hatte, also ein Hemd ist nicht so gut finde ich, wo du die Ärmel nicht hochschieben
kannst, weil die beste Kombination für mich im Rechenzentrum war immer Pulli und Ärmel
hochgeschoben. Das war eigentlich so die optimale Konfig. Und man hört das im Hintergrund
vielleicht, du hast hier bei den Kisten jetzt weniger, das sind Desktop-PCs, die werden
jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel pusten mit Lüftern, aber wenn du hinter größeren Surfern
stehst, die haben auch schon, es ist vielleicht jetzt kein Flugzeug beim Starten, aber die
haben auch schon, da ist auch schon ganz schön Luftbewegung drinne. Ist so beste ne Option?
Ja, kann man bestimmt auch machen. Wobei das praktische ist halt beim Pulli kannst du die
Ärmel einfach runterziehen, wenn es dir zu kalt wird.
Ich soll mich nicht wundern, dass es so unordentlich ist.
Quatsch ist doch gar nicht unordentlich.
Das ist schon hier perfekte Ordnung.
Das ist doch nicht unordentlich.
Die sollten mal das Kabelsalat bei mir zu Hause sehen. Da bin ich sehr gespannt, wie
das dann in der neueren Rechenzentrum gleich noch aussieht.
Ja gut, du kannst da hier gar nicht. Was willst du hier großartig machen? Du hast hier keine
Möglichkeit irgendwie Switche 19 Zoll einzubauen, das funktioniert ja gar nicht. Also für
das hier im Feld ist das eigentlich super ordentlich, kannst dich überhaupt nicht beschweren.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt, wie das dann in der neueren Rechenzentrum gleich noch aussieht.
Neben mir habe ich den Michel von Hetzner. Ich habe dich schon mal gefragt, wie jetzt
letztendlich die Klimaanlage funktioniert. Du hast mir ja gesagt, es läuft zwar durch
den Boden und geht dann hoch, aber wo kommt die kalte Luft her? Oder du hast auch gesagt,
die ist ja eigentlich gar nicht so kalt.
Die Umgebungsluft sind so um die 28 Grad und wir saugen die Luft von außen an. Und dann
sind die riesen Radiallüfter im Unterboden. Also wir sind ca. 1 Meter hoch und die verteilen
dann die Luft im Boden und dann steigt die kalte Luft in den Kaminen.
Also so Klima- und Kältetechnik und sowas für Rechner, das ist echt eine Wissenschaft
für sich, da habe ich auch gar keinen Plan von.
Und aktuell sind die Klimaanlagen auch im Mischbetrieb. Also das heißt, wir nutzen
die warme Luft zum Kühlen der Surfer, weil die Außentemperatur viel niedriger ist als
die Luft. Mischbetrieb heißt dann, dass ihr die Luft, die hier drin ist, verwendet, zusätzlich
mit kalter Luft von außen, aber die Klimaanlage selber läuft ja gar nicht. Du hast vorhin
schonmal angesprochen, die Klimaanlage generell, was ja auch den Strom verbraucht und stark
beeinflusst, läuft bei euch nur wenige Tage.
Ich finde das lustig, ne? So irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, 5 Zuschauer-Leute rennen da
mit einem riesen Mikrofon rum und alles und der Bauer kommt einfach mit seinem Ansteck-Mikro.
Geht aber qualitativ vollkommen in Ordnung, ne?
Ja, beeindruckend, weil ich dachte, so ein Rechenzentrum muss alles immer aktiv gekühlt
werden, aber das ist gar nicht der Fall.
Nein, jetzt bei uns ist es eh nicht so extrem heiß in der Umgebung.
Mittlerweile nicht mehr. Also wie gesagt, früher hat man die Rechenzentrum viel kühler
eingestellt, bis man dann auf den Drichter gekommen ist und hat gesagt, hey, die paar
Grad bringen die Teile nicht um und spart halt extrem. Also ich kann es euch nicht in
den Eishallen sagen, aber ihr könnt von ausgehen, dass der Unterschied 18 zu 24 Grad massiv,
also massiv, kosteneinspart bei der Klimaanlage.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie viel es wirklich sind, ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich das rechnen
soll, aber ihr könnt davon ausgehen, ich gehe davon aus, dass es wirklich viel ist.
Wir brauchen jetzt gar nicht so extrem runterkühlen, da die 22 Grad auch relativ gut zu erreichen
sind mit den Umgebungsumreinungen.
Das hat er nachgesprochen eben, oder?
Meistens sind es ja um die 20 Grad im Herbst, im Winter immer kühler, im Sommer über 30
Grad ist eher selten, da müssen wir jetzt nicht so viel die Klimaanlage aktiv benutzen.
Okay, cool. Mir wurde auch gerade gesagt, dass man ja auch die natürliche Konvektion
ausnutzt, dementsprechend ist das Dach über uns auch schräg. Vielleicht können wir uns
das von oben mal kurz anschauen?
Ja.
Das ist allgemein ein älteres, kleineres Rechenzentrum, wo nur Midis so verwendet werden.
3, 9, 11 habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, ich glaube, die waren das, dass ich bei denen
mal was hausten wollte, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob die das waren. Die wollten
den Ausweis eingescannt, hatte ich keinen Bock.
Bei Hetzer ging das alles so.
Euren Rechenzentrum mit unserem eigenen Racksystem, ja, sind die Rechenzentrum schon deutlich
größer.
Wie viele sind hier, also wie viele stehen hier, klar, man könnte das natürlich zählen
und kurz durchrechnen.
Mir wurde gerade gesagt, ca. 14.000 PCs hier und hier oben ist es auch nochmal echt ein
gutes Stück wärmer als unten. Das merkt man, ich habe jetzt auch mein Pulli ausgezogen.
Das dachte ich mir schon.
Ja, also die Luft, die sie zum Kühlen verwenden, die hat ja ca. 20.
Deswegen, was habe ich gesagt, Pulli und Ärmel hochziehen, weil wenn man viel unterwegs
ist.
Gerade, wenn dann die angesorgt wird in den PCs.
Hetzer will auch den Ausweis eingescannt, ich habe bis heute keinen Ausweis da eingescannt.
Natürlich, wenn die rauskommt, dann ist hier ein gutes Stück wärmer.
Aber ich benutze nur Hetzer Cloud.
Und die Konvektion führt dazu, dass die warme Luft hier hoch steigt.
Deswegen ist es übrigens hier oben auch offen, also die warme Luft, die kann dann einfach
hier schön nach oben abziehen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Mission Impossible, also wenn ich Tom Cruise wäre,
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich hier einsteigen.
Und so, wir sind jetzt in einem Bereich, der ein bisschen neuer ist, da geht auch gleich
die Tür auf, hallo, hallo.
Auf jeden Fall, wenn man hier reinkommt, da merkt man schon, hier ist es richtig warm,
deutlich wärmer als drüben.
Und wenn ihr das mal so betrachtet, das sieht im Ansatz ein bisschen nach 19 Zoll aus, wobei
es ein bisschen schmal ist, nee, das ist weil er so weit weg ist.
Nee, hier oben ist ein ganz normales Patch-Panel und ein feuchtes Switch, wasche ich nicht.
Also vielleicht sitzt das 19 Zoll und das ist einfach die Tür hier vorne.
Da hingehen und uns das von hinten anschauen, dann sieht man direkt, hier sind keine Meaty
Tower mehr, das ist alles schon deutlich moderner.
Das ist gar nicht so warm, das ist schon schon warm, warm, aber jetzt nicht heiß.
Das ist auf jeden Fall auch Special-Hetzner-Konstruktion hier.
Okay, da bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt am Ende.
Temperaturtechnisch.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht normal, also.
Das kann ja im Prinzip nur sein, dass man den Fluss von warm zu kalt umdrehen will.
Ich hab jetzt den Hendrik bei mir, wir haben jetzt gerade hier oben, also wir sind jetzt
gerade hier hochgelaufen und schauen uns das einfach von oben mal an, nur damit jemand
einen Vergleich bekommt, wie sieht das aus, wenn das was Neueres ist, wirklich in dem,
wo wir gerade herkommen.
Und jetzt hast du gesagt gerade, das fand ich ganz interessant, das ist ja nicht mal
19 Zoll Standard quasi, ihr baut ja keinen Standard, ihr macht ja alles selber.
Genau, das ist so ein bisschen unser Ding bei Hetzner, wir machen unsere Sachen selbst.
Das ist kein 19 Zoll System, wir haben das selbst aufgezogen, das ist an unsere Bedürfnisse
angepasst ein Stück weit, wir haben da festgestellt, dass eben diese Höhe, diese Breite bei uns
am besten reinpasst, dass wir damit die Flasche am effektivsten ausmützen können.
Hetzner ist ein Anbieter, da macht das Sinn, da kann ich das voll ganz verstehen, ich meine
die verdienen ihr Geld damit, wenn man jetzt irgendwo in Frankfurt einen Technikraum hat
und zwei Racks reinstellt, dann ist es natürlich nicht sinnvoll, da selbst was zu bauen.
Wir können auch so die Gehäuse selbst produzieren, produzieren lassen, das Racksystem, da sind
wir einfach flexibel, wo wir was anfassen wollen und so weiter.
Die müssen ja auch auf jeden Cent kommen.
Der Kran verkauft sich halt zu 90% erstmal über den Preis, klar Hetzner hat auch einen
guten Ruf, kann man nichts sagen, das macht natürlich auch noch viel dabei aus und an
sich Preis-Leistungs-mäßig ist bei Hetzner halt einfach top und die müssen wahrscheinlich
wirklich auf jeden Cent gucken, dass das passt, wenn das jetzt auf einmal irgendwie doppelt
so viel kostet, dann haben die Leute da keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Mich würde eh mal interessieren, inwieweit das Impact hatte, die Server wurden jetzt
ja letztens irgendwie 1,50 oder 2 Euro oder so teuer, teurer wegen IPv4 Adresse, ich hoffe
mal, dass es bald welche gibt, ohne, komplett ohne Public IP, weil gerade, gerade Backend
Sachen, mit dem Load Balancer davor brauchst du ja gar keine Public IP, ist das sicherheits-nicht
bedenklich, dass die Gebäude offen, oben offen sind, tja normalerweise würde ich sagen,
das ist keine allzu gute Idee, aber die werden sich da schon was bei gedacht haben, vielleicht
haben die auch Security, was da durchläuft, keine Ahnung, normalerweise würde ich jetzt
nicht unbedingt das Fenster, die Fenster auflassen in meinem Rechenzentrum, außer ich bin in
Frankfurt, keine Ahnung, im achten Stock oder so, ja, ich weiß nicht, wie es da Security-technisch
aussieht, erstmal würde ich sagen, keine so gute Idee, aber je nachdem, was da für
ein Sicherheitskonzept drum herum ist, warum nicht, ich glaube nicht, dass die das irgendwie
unüberlegt machen, wo wir gerade her kamen, hier oben ist es ja so ein bisschen offen,
also wir können jetzt unten, vielleicht gehen wir mal ein bisschen nach links rüber, da
kann man das ein bisschen besser sehen, ja hier sieht man es auch ganz gut, dass es ein
bisschen ist in der Richtung, wie ich es vorher gesagt habe, du hast eine Tür und du hast
oben zu, so machst du das normalerweise auch, da geht das nämlich mit der Klimaanlage auch
deutlich besser, im Boden diese Gitter drin, also zwischen diesen zwei Reihen, da strömt
dann die kalte Luft nach innen hoch und wird dann durch die Server durchgedruckt, aber
gleichzeitig auch durchgezogen, also die Servers sind selber auch nochmal gekühlt, wurde
auch gerade gesagt, dass gerade die, die hinten so Lüfter dran haben, also wo wir gerade davor
standen, da sind auch viele AMD Epic Server zum Beispiel dabei und die haben ja auch schon
eine etwas größere Leistungsaufnahme, das heißt, Kühlung ist natürlich das A und O
auf jeden Fall.
Ja gut, Gitter muss auf jeden Fall davor sein, sonst kommen ja Vögel rein, alles Mögliche.
250.000 Server, da muss man natürlich auch ein bisschen was an Daten speichern, dazu
sind die auch da, dementsprechend gibt es auch mal die ein oder andere HDD, die das
Ganze vielleicht nicht so lange überlebt, deswegen sitze ich jetzt hier einfach mal
auf dem Stabel HDDs, die alle nicht mehr funktionieren, die werden natürlich professionell
entzeugt, professionell recycelt, natürlich auch, dass die Daten auch hundertprozentig
erst mal durchgebohrt sind und zerstört vor allem, weil ansonsten, wenn man das jetzt
einfach nur so weghaut, weiß man ja nie, ob das letztendlich auch tatsächlich gelöscht
ist.
Erst mal schön die Festbade hinterkloppen.
Die müssen ja auch irgendwo gebaut werden, das passiert hier.
Wir sind jetzt hier in der Produktion, das ist natürlich immer so ganz spannend zu
sehen, was hier an Hardware rumliegt, erst mal hier, Massac Mainboards, ich will nichts
anfassen, weil sonst mache ich tendenziell immer Sachen kaputt, das wollen wir hier
auf jeden Fall nicht.
Wir sehen hier aber auch viele Teile von der Kühlung, ich glaube, das kann ich mir
anfassen, ohne dass ich etwas kaputt mache.
Hier sind so typische Server-Heatsinks, wie man die kennt, logischerweise ohne Lüfter.
Wir haben ja schon mal kurz angerissen, wie das Kühlkonzept grundsätzlich ist.
Lüfter brauchst du da logischerweise nicht drauf, falls es durch das Gehäuse durchzieht.
Das funktioniert eben dadurch, dass die Luft rausgezogen wird aus dem Server, deswegen
liegen hier auch so Luftkanäle noch rum.
Wir werden es wahrscheinlich gleich noch anschauen, wie so ein Server mal gebaut wird.
Ansonsten massige Kühlung, viel Hardware, hier viel CPUs, hier haben wir einfach mal
so ein, wie ich das jetzt fallen lasse, hier ist ein ganzes Tray, Ryzen 9 3900, da unten
noch mal welche drunter, hier sind 8700 ohne K, hier sind 9900 mit K, also das ist auch
etwas, was ich extrem spannend finde, Hetzner verwendet auch ganz viel Consumer-Hardware,
die haben da auch sehr viele Frauen mit.
Kann ich verstehen, ich meine ganz ehrlich, da wo es wirklich auf den letzten Cent ankommt,
ob das jetzt irgendein Xeon ist oder eine 9600 K oder was auch immer, juck doch nicht die
Bohne, wenn du das Ding einkaufst, quasi als Service oder halt als fertige Kiste, wäre
mir vollkommen egal.
Gerade unter diesem Aspekt spannend, weil viele, ich hoffe von euch nicht, ihr kennt
euch ja auch aus mit Hardware, aber viele machen sich viel zu viele Gedanken, was so
die Langlebigkeit von Hardware und sowas betrifft und da sieht man einfach, dass man
in Servern sogar zuverlässig Consumer-Hardware, wie eben so ein Ryzen 9 verwenden kann und
der funktioniert hier mit Dauerlast wunderbar Tag für Tag und das machen die ja schon seit
vielen Jahren und da sieht man, was so kurz wie möglich aushalten kann.
Okay, dann schauen wir jetzt hoffentlich mal die Produktion.
Es ist ja auch, da hat er schon recht, also da wird sich eh generell zu viel Gedanken
gemacht, manche Leute denken ja, hey ich will einen Minecraft-Server betreiben oder
einen Next-Lord betreiben oder sonst was, das muss irgendwie Server-Hardware sein, was
Server und was Desktop-Hardware ist, das ist äußerst fließend, der hauptsächliche Unterschied
ist eigentlich, ob das 19 Zoll Bauweise ist oder nicht, aber was dann da drinnen steckt,
ist eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Baste live von so einem Server an.
Wir schauen uns jetzt mal den Bau von einem spezifischen Server an und wenn ihr das hier
seht, dann fällt euch mal direkt auf, dass es kein normales baut.
Das ist das, was ich schon erwähnt hatte, zumindest für die meisten Anwendungen.
Klar, wenn jetzt irgendwie einer mit ECC ankommt für ZFS oder irgendwelche Oracle-Datenbanken,
wo die Lizenz schon zehnmal mehr kostet als die Hardware, ja, meinetwegen, es gibt immer
Ausnahmen, aber für 90% der Sachen, die ihr drauf laufen lassen wollt, ist es vollkommen
egal, ob das jetzt normales RAM, ECC-RAM ist, Xeon-CPU oder was auch immer, es ist wurscht.
Dass sich natürlich auch eigene Boards für die eigenen Anwendungen bauen lässt und wurde
mir gerade erklärt, ich kannte das tatsächlich nicht, d.h. Pro WS 565 ACE und der Chipsatz
ist ein Pro 565, was ich daran interessant fand tatsächlich, mir wurde auch gesagt,
vielleicht wollen wir das ja nicht sagen mit dem Overclocking, aber ich finde es sehr interessant
und auch wirklich wichtig, dieser Chipsatz verhindert, dass man übertakten kann, macht
ja auch absolut Sinn, weil das ganze Kühlkonzept, das jetzt hier drin steckt mit dem Kühler,
der jetzt irgendwo da drin sitzt, schauen wir uns gleich alles an, verhindert, dass man
übertakken kann, das ist eine echt clevere Idee, da bin ich ja noch gar nicht drauf
gekommen, wenn du dir wirklich einen Hood-Server bestellst und mit Access zu allem, wer hindert
dich denn das Ding zu übertakken?
Und dann gehen die Hardware kaputt, wenn die anderen den Kram übertaken, da habe ich ja
noch gar nicht dran gedacht, dass Leute auf die Idee kommen, könnten sich den Server
zu mieten und den zu übertakken, gut, cloud-technisch ist das kein Ding, das sind VMs, da kannst
du nix übertakken, aber wenn du dir einen kompletten Server mietest, auf die Idee bin
ich ja noch gar nicht gekommen, ja stimmt, stimmt, es gibt bestimmt Leute, die haben
gesagt, dass ich übertakte das Teil, alles vorgetestet, vordefiniert, das ist eigentlich
eine richtig schlaue, clevere Idee, auch top funktioniert und lange funktioniert und sicher
funktioniert.
Wenn wir jetzt natürlich da hingehen und bauen da, in dem Fall ist es ein 550X, wenn
wir den jetzt übertakken und dann hat er seine 250W Abwärme, dann wird es wahrscheinlich
schwer das Ding zu kühlen, nicht nur CPU zu kühlen, sondern ist ja auch die Belastung
für die Spannungsverhandler und sowas eine andere, deswegen passt das auch, fand ich
sehr interessant, ich wusste gar nicht, dass...
Ja, das Rechenzentrum wird nicht abfackeln, Chad, aber die Hardware geht vielleicht kaputt
oder aber, wenn das zu viele Leute machen, gibt es ja auch Probleme mit der Kühlung
insgesamt, weil wenn man sich vorstellt, das ist ja schon genau berechnet, natürlich haben
die da ein bisschen Spielraum, aber das wird schon so berechnet, dass das preisleistungsmäßig
auch passt, was die Kühlung kostet, dass die Kühlung ausreichend ist, ein bisschen
aufhört, sonst wie was, und wenn jetzt auf einmal die Leute auf die Idee kommen, in so
einem kompletten Würfel 80% der Kisten zu übertakken, zufälligerweise in Kombination,
dann klappt das mit der Kühlung nicht mehr.
Wahrscheinlich reicht es schon 20%
Das verhindert es ja nicht, sondern erlaubt es noch nicht.
Würfel, das nennt man so, man nennt das wirklich Würfel.
Extrem abgespecktes Mainboard, weil die ganzen anderen Sachen, wozu Wi-Fi, wozu Bluetooth,
einfach mal alles nicht, ich würde sagen, wir schauen uns jetzt einfach mal den Zusammenbau
so ein bisschen an.
Auch der Bau der Server selbst ist sehr praxisorientiert, das sieht man schon am Gehäuse selber, das
Gehäuse selber ist einfach nur ein simples Pleniteil.
Und dieser Stromverbrauch, stimmt, kommt auch noch dabei.
Das wird auch in Deutschland gefertigt, da achtet Hetzen auch darauf, dass alles, was
in Deutschland gefertigt werden kann, auch in Deutschland gefertigt wird, das finde
ich extrem vorbildlich.
Ansonsten ist der Bau sehr ähnlich einem relativ normalen Desktop-PC, weil die Komponenten
ja letztendlich auch abgespeckte Desktop-Komponenten sind, Netzteil zum Beispiel ist ein bisschen
angepasst, dass die Kabel kürzer sind, dass man das Kabelmanagement sich ein bisschen
einfacher macht und man nicht unnötig Komponenten verwendet oder verschwendet, die man sonst
nicht brauchen würde.
Warum überhaupt Kabelmanagement?
Warum nicht alles WLAN?
Das ist ein fertigen AX101, ne bloß nicht, kommt bloß nicht auf die Idee, so Zeug zu
machen, Leute.
Eben daran besonders ist oder was auf jeden Fall erwähnenswert ist, ist eben das Kühlkonzept.
Also hier seht ihr eben so einen großen Schlauch, hier hinten sitzt der Lüfter, das ist das,
was wir vorhin gesehen haben.
Ah, jetzt ergibt das Sinn.
Ja, okay.
Und hier wird die CPU gekühlt, also hier der CPU-Kühler drunter und auch der RAM wird
damit bedacht, das sieht man auch schon hier, da gibt es Ausschnitte.
Da hat übrigens bei uns auch mal die Leute Probleme, die haben die Switches, also die
haben Netzwerk-Komponenten falsch herum eingebaut und das Ding hat dann permanent gemeckert,
dass es zu heiß ist.
So, und dann hat man das allerdings schon, dann hat man Probleme gehabt und ich glaube
die Lösung danach war dann nicht einfach zu sagen, wir bauen das nochmal aus und drehen
das um, sondern die haben die Lüfter umgedreht.
Das ging wohl bei diesem Switch halbwegs, aber der Weisatz letzter Schluss war es garantiert
nicht.
Der RAM wird auch gut mitgekühlt, also der ist dann mit im Kühlkanal automatisch drin,
das ist ein ganz anderes Kühlkonzept oder eine andere Kühlrichtung, als man das beim
normalen Desktop-PC hat.
Und auch hier hinten, interessantes Detail, ich weiß nicht, ich kann das vielleicht nicht
sehen, wir blenden es vielleicht ansonsten von einem anderen PC noch ein, aber da gibt
es dann auch noch einen kleinen Ausschnitt, dass die Spannungsunder, die oben sitzen,
auch so ein bisschen kalte Luft noch mit abbekommen, aber so sieht es eben der fertige Server dann
aus.
Wir saßen ja gerade schon auf einem Stapel von defekten Fässern.
Aber das Kühlkonzept an sich, das ist relativ ähnlich zu dem, wie du es auch mit Standard-Sachen
im Rechenzentrum hast.
Du hast hier einen Kaltgang und du hast dann halt hoffentlich jede Menge in richtiger
Richtung eingebaute Server und Netzwerk-Hardware, sodass die alle in die gleiche Richtung pusten.
Oder saugen, besser gesagt.
Ob die kaputt sind oder ob die vielleicht gar kein Problem haben und der Kunde nur
gedacht hat, die hat vielleicht ein Problem.
Das Ganze passiert hier.
Hier werden HDDs getestet in Massen.
Das ist auch ganz geil, ich finde es auch einfach, die Masse an HDDs ist auch mega schön.
Da sind immer so Status-LEDs dran.
Hier sieht man jetzt, die blinken alle schön, das bedeutet, die HDDs werden gerade getestet.
Also die haben hier wirklich ziemlich viel selbst am Start, finde ich cool.
Seht ihr zum Beispiel, hier blinkt eine LED schnell.
Das bedeutet, diese HDD hat irgendein Problem.
Die anderen, die blinken so langsam ab, hier blinkt auch eine schnell.
Also diese zwei HDDs, die scheinen tatsächlich defekt zu sein und dann werden die natürlich
getauscht und der Kunde bekommt eine neue.
Hier ist die Zuordnung dann am Gehäuse und da sind die 1, 2, 3, 4.
Die testen noch, bei dem langsamen Blinken, 5 ist schon fertig, die ist gut befunden und
6 und 7 testen hier noch.
Also Hetzen hat definitiv eine andere Definition von Perfektion oder sauberen Arbeiten, Organisation
als ich.
Ich kann hier rein denken, ey das ist alles so krass strukturiert, alles mega ordentlich.
Auch das ist für mich mega ordentlich, weil alles alles strukturiert ist.
Die HDDs stehen alle schön in Reihung.
Ich kenne das gleiche Problem, bei mir ist hier daheim auch alles wie Sau, wobei man sagen
muss, du hast ab einer gewissen Größe hast du natürlich ganz andere Probleme.
Das ist wie, wenn ich das hier früher, wo ich noch beim Provider war, mit dem Rechenzentrum
vergleiche und bei mir daheim, das ist einfach so ab einer gewissen Größe blickst du nicht
mehr durch.
Und gerade wenn du Rechner patchen musstest oder sowas und du musstest dann die richtigen
Ports finden, eine gewisse Ordnung, ich meine das muss nicht alles wie geleckt aussehen.
Wir haben uns ja mal ein Video angeguckt von irgendwie, wie war das, in Co-Location-Ding
in London oder was das war, wo das alles wie geleckt war, wo die sogar die Kabel selbst
gekrimpt haben dafür.
Das muss nicht sein, aber du solltest zumindest in der Lage sein Wartungsarbeiten durchzuführen
ohne das von anderen Leuten kaputt zu machen.
Das ist daheim ja gar nicht der Fall, da gibt es nur dich.
Für mich ist das auch schon richtig krass, aber die haben gesagt, ne ne, das müssen wir
noch ein bisschen besser machen, deswegen haben sie dann angefangen hier noch so Halter
3D zu drucken, wo sie dann die LED, die Status-LED direkt in den Halter eingepackt haben und
so sind sie dann zufrieden.
Also schon krass, auf was für Details sie so achten.
Sollten die Festplatten nicht liegen?
Ja normalerweise schon, aber ich glaube das ist auch was, was ziemlich überbewertet wird,
gerade bei aktuellen Festplatten.
Im Magnet, wo wir am Anfang waren, wo wir oben drauf geschaut haben mit diesen Doppelreihen,
also wo wir 700 Server pro Reihe haben.
Ich glaube das wichtigste bei Magnet Festplatten ist, dass du sie nicht bewegst, während sie
an sind.
Wenn ich nach rechts schauen würde, dann haben wir da auf einer Seite 700 und auf der anderen
Seite nochmal 700.
An der Stelle muss ich auch einfach mal Danke sagen an Hetzner, dass ich überhaupt mal
hier sein darf, weil ich mein ich könnte jetzt auch hier einfach wahllos irgendeine
Stecke rausziehen und sind ja hier auch wichtige Sachen drauf.
Er möchte ja weiter Hetzner Partner bleiben.
Das sind Server, die in der ganzen Welt verwendet werden, also nicht nur deutsche Sachen.
Ich weiß doch, dazu fällt mir was geiles ein.
Ich war mal mit zwei Praktikanten im Rechenzentrum.
Früher, das ist schon eine Weile her.
Ich hab irgendwas im Halsdeck.
Ich war mal mit zwei Praktikanten im Rechenzentrum und das sieht, das sahen bei uns dann auch
ungefähr so aus wie hier.
Natürlich waren das andere Racks und so.
Da stand ich ungefähr auch da, hab denen was erklärt und dann dreh ich mich um und
dann lehnt der eine ohne Scheiß, der eine Praktikant, der war langweilig, der lehnt
an so einem Schrank, so in die Kabel rein.
Da war ich auch jetzt nicht bewegen, mach mal langsam, okay, langsam weg, geguckt, nicht,
ich mein da sind Glasfaserkabel drin, wenn man sich dagegen lehnt, ist in der Regel
meistens nicht so gut und der Kelder war echt unbelehrbar, wenn du da nicht hingeguckt hast,
der hat auch irgendwo dran rumgefuddelt.
Also wir waren da glaube ich eine Viertelstunde drin, hab ich gesagt, komm wir gehen jetzt
wieder rüber, bevor da noch irgendwas kaputt geht.
Also die haben das wörtlich genommen, die haben wirklich, also der eine nicht, der eine
hat es ganz normal verhalten, aber der andere, das war schon ein spezieller Kandidat.
Glasfaserkabel knicken für Performance Boost, du meinst, dass die Übertragungswege kürzer
werden, aber ich mein, ist ja klar, wenn man so ein Glasfaserkabel, wenn das so liegt,
ist natürlich der Weg länger, wie wenn das so liegt, sind wir uns ja einig, also im Prinzip,
so ist natürlich die optimale Anordnung für Glasfaserkabel selbstverständlich, dann ist
der Weg kürzer.
National, das ist natürlich schon auch, ja, an dieser Stelle vielen Dank an Herzen für
das Vertrauen, dass wir überhaupt hier machen dürfen und euch auch zeigen dürfen, dass
die so offen sind und wir uns das alles anfassen.
Mich würde interessieren, wer auf die Idee gekommen ist, die Marketing-Abteilung auf
die Idee gekommen oder ist er auf die Idee gekommen, wahrscheinlich ist das in gegenseitiger
Absprache entstanden.
Wir sind jetzt hier übrigens gerade in diesem sogenannten Kaltgang, das heißt unter uns
kommt diese Kaltluft raus und ich würde sagen, so geschätzt ist es eben so circa 20 Grad,
könnte gut hinkommen, fühlt sich eben kühl an durch den Wind, aber eigentlich ist es
nicht so kalt und geht dann hier hoch, geht dann durch die ganzen Server zur Seite raus
und draußen ist es dann wieder schluckig warm, also wo wir gerade draußen waren, da
waren es eher so 30 Grad Celsius.
Deswegen, das was er anspricht ist genau das, deswegen finde ich ein Pulli, wo du die Ärmel
leicht hoch machen kannst und die dann nach oben bleiben am besten für das Rechenzentrum.
Einfach beeindruckend.
Hier haben wir jetzt nochmal den AX101, also von dem haben wir uns den Bau gerade so ein
bisschen angeschaut, so sieht er dann im Einsatz aus.
Hier auf der rechten Seite sind jetzt noch zwei SSDs hier drin, hier oben haben wir noch
einen AX161, der ist dann mit dem AMD Epic 7502P, also für Single-CPU quasi und hier
oben den AX41, den kennt ihr aus den Werbespots von mir, Ryzen 5 3600, also verglichen mit
dem was wir am Anfang gesehen haben, ist das hier natürlich aktuellste Hardware und auch
aktuellstes Design, was Kühlung, Wreck und so weiter betrifft.
Es könnte ja rein theoretisch auch mal passieren, dass der Strom ausfällt, will man ja alles
nicht, dafür gibt es natürlich Notstromaggregate und bis sowas mal anläuft, gibt es zu Überbrückung
auch solche Batterieräume hier und dieser Batterierraum, den wir hier sehen, der ist
nur für dieses eine Rechenzentrum, wo wir gerade waren, also das, was wir von oben
gesehen haben.
Also ganz ehrlich, das habe ich so noch nie gesehen, dass du wirklich die Batterien von
der USB da hängen hast, aber warum nicht, ja, innen drinnen sieht es bei den meisten
größeren USBs wahrscheinlich so aus, ich habe da noch ehrlich gesagt noch nie reingekuckt.
Hab ich so noch nie gesehen, nicht so, wenn ich mich bisher groß beschäftigt habe, aber
warum nicht, ich meine, du brauchst halt irgendwo den Kram, also warum sollte das nicht einfach
so da stehen.
In so einem Bereich wird eben von so einem Batterieraum hier abgedeckt und hier sieht
man, das sind Bly-Akkus, also hier seht ihr PV, Bly, also im Prinzip Autobatterien, so
könnte man es ganz einfach sagen, aber was auffällt, also wenn man so mal draufschaut
und steht da oben drauf, das sind 2 Volt, also ein so ein Ding hat anscheinend 2 Volt
und dann sind ganz viele von denen in eine Reihe geschaltet, also wahrscheinlich ein
so ein Block, den man hier sehen kann, 2 Volt, kann man sich hier ausrechnen, dann schaltet
man 120 in eine Reihe, dann hat man schöne 240 Volt, zumindest mal Gleichstrom, keine
Ahnung, wie die das genau aufgebaut haben, aber auf jeden Fall reicht das hier, um 15
Minuten zu überbrücken, falls der Strom ausfallen würde und das reicht natürlich, also normalerweise
diese Situation sollte es normalerweise nie geben.
Na das kann man so nicht sagen, doch, doch, doch, hier Chat, bei Stromausfall funktioniert
doch normalerweise auch das, ja bei dir da heimlich, weil deine Router und sonstige
Dinger ja auch ausgefallen sind, aber in der Regel hast du da gar kein Problem mit
deiner Anbindung bei einem Stromausfall, also wenn du dein, sag mal, normalerweise ist
es ja so, wenn du ein bisschen größere Rechenzentrum oder größere Anbindung hast,
das ist ja meistens eh ein Glasfaserkabel und wenn das Seiten das Zeug an ist, das
ist eigentlich kein Problem, wenn natürlich jetzt die ganze Stadt weg ist, dann ist das
was anderes, aber auch wenn das ein ganz normales AR45 Kabel ist oder so, wenn auf beiden Seiten
das funktioniert, ist kein Problem, also das ist, also gut, sag mal, wenn die ganze Stadt
weg ist vielleicht, aber ansonsten, ist das kein grossartiges Problem, bist du elektriert?
Nein, bin ich nicht, aber wir hatten schon Stromausfälle und es ist nichts passiert,
also ich weiß aus praktischer Erfahrung, dass da nichts passiert, ja Moment, ich rede
nicht von Telekom DSL Anschluss oder Vodafone, sondern wir reden hier auch von ein bisschen
anderen Anbindungen, entweder über Glasfaser oder von irgendeinem Provider, den man dafür
bezahlt das zu machen, das geht ja dann auch nicht über normale Telekom oder Vodafone
Leitungen, sondern das sind dann entweder Schächte, wo Glasfaser schon drin liegt,
aber halt nicht verwendet oder irgendwie der eigene Backbone Infrastruktur über die
Stadt verteilt, das ist ja dann nicht wirklich das genau, zum Beispiel, Darkfiber heißt
übrigens Darkfiber, nicht weil das Licht irgendwie dunkel ist, sondern weil es quasi
Rohre und Glasfasern sind, die halt schon da liegen, weil sie sonst nicht verwendet sind,
die sind halt dark, weil die aus sind, weil die sind halt da, kann auch sein, dass ich
Mist erzähle, aber ich bilde mir ein, ich hab das mal, ich hab das mal so gelernt, dass
das wenigstens so heißt, also da geht meistens nichts kaputt, so weiter, aber wir hatten
schon Stromausfälle und dabei ist nichts passiert, wir haben die Möglichkeit 1,3 Megawatt zu
liefern, das ist natürlich schon, das ist echt viel für Batterien, die Kühlung des
Servers ist ja so absolutes Relevanteste überhaupt und wir haben beim Aufbau gesehen, alles hängt
letztendlich an einem einzelnen Lüfter im Server, deswegen testet Hetzen auch alle
Lüfter selbst und verlässt sich nicht auf die Hersteller, die haben hier einen Langzeittest
aufgebaut, wo die Lüfter über mehrere Jahre laufen, direkt über der USB, da ist es 40
Grad warm und dementsprechend auch ein bisschen wärmer in der Regel als das, was bei dem Server
hinten rauskommt, somit ist die Belastung höher und weil die hier dauerhaft laufen...
Findest du MacBooks?
Ich hab keins, keine Ahnung, kann dir nichts zu sagen.
Ich finde es ein bisschen minimalistisch, seit sie angefangen haben mit nur einem USB-Anschluss.
Bei Hetzener sieht alles so selber gebastelt aus, ja das mag daran liegen, dass es auch
alles zum größten Teil selber gebastelt ist, das macht vielleicht für die meisten Betreiber
keinen Sinn, bei Hetzener, gerade bei einem Hosting-Anbieter, wo es viel um Preis-Leistung
geht, ist das eine der wenigen Fällen, wo ich sage, hey ich verstehe es und das scheint
mir auch sinnvoll zu sein.
... wo wir ein Ausfallproblem hätten und dann werden die getauscht bzw. werden in der Zukunft
dann eben andere Modelle eingekauft.
So sieht übrigens so ein Lüfter aus, der die Luft durch den Boden schiebt, also wenn
man sich überlegt, das Ding läuft mal schnell, das sind schon ganz schöne Oschis.
Wir sind jetzt im Testlab angekommen, denn Hetzener muss natürlich auch für internen
Sachen testen, auch für externen, also wenn jetzt neue Plattformen rauskommen, neue CPUs,
muss man Kompatibilität testen, passt diese CPU mit diesem Mainboard, mit diesem Arbeitsspeicher
gut zusammen, mit anderen Geräten, das kann natürlich erstmal für die interne Verwendung
sein oder auch falls jemand von externen kommt und sagt, ich hätte gerne 100 Server damit
und die konfiguriert...
Erstmal hier schön T-MAX mit Custom Config, ne, das ist ein Windows oder, so eine Startleiste,
ach keine Ahnung.
So einen haben die vielleicht nicht, dann müssen die das vielleicht auch intern testen, deswegen
stehen hier verschiedene Konfigurationen, wo die verschiedene Sachen testen, z.B.
hier vorne haben wir erstmal ein System, da werden dediziert immer SSDs zum Beispiel
getestet oder Laufwerke generell und wenn wir jetzt mal hier weitergehen, haben wir hier
ein etwas interessanteres System, weil da wird gerade die Temperatur im Spannungswanderbereich
gemessen, da sieht man ja jetzt so eine Wärmebildkamera und die ist jetzt hier auf den Spannungswanderbereich
gerichtet und da wird einfach dann z.B.
Prime95 oder sowas laufen gelassen und dann checken die, ey passt das so oder lasst, weil
die Bedingungen, die hier in dem Raum sind, sind die gleichen wie außerhalb, also auch
hier ist die Belüftung von unten und die Luft geht nach oben raus, d.h. hier alles kühlungstechnisch
ist genau das gleiche, wie das dann im Serverzustand später auflädt und so können wir es einfach
nachvollziehen, ey passt das so mit der Kühlung, sind die Spannungswander dann kalt genug oder
der Arbeitsspeicher oder die SSDs oder wie auch immer, hier haben wir nochmal einen
speziellen und wie ich finde persönlich ein sehr interessantes...
Das Ding sieht ja mal, also das Board sieht mal richtig oldschool aus, ja.
Auf den ersten Blick ist man nur ein grünes Board, denke ich muss ich euch...
Wobei so oldschool scheint das gar nicht zu sein, das ist, glaubt das ist zur Abwechslung
schonmal ein Serverboard.
Das hier ist, das ist ein extra Raid Controller wahrscheinlich drin.
SROG REC, jawoll, das ist glaube ich das in Xeon D, kann das sein?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Okay, typisches Serverboard, hier switchen wir einfach mal hier nach rechts, da seht ihr
das Board nämlich im unbeschückten Zustand, also der Chipsatz ist auch wieder dieser Pro
565, den wir vorhin gesehen haben, aber was sehr interessant ist, ist die Tatsache, dass
hier der Sockel gedreht ist, weil viele von euch kennen das von dem EVGA Darkboard und
nehmen wahrscheinlich an, dass EVGA das einzige Unternehmen ist, das Sockel drehen kann, aber
ihr seht, das ist das SROG REC Board, also auch SROG kann das, es ist ja auch kein Riesenhexenwerk,
was daran interessant ist, die RAM-Module sitzen hier, die sitzen normalerweise ja da
und durch diese spezielle Ausrichtung, jetzt können wir da nach links überswitchen, da
sehen wir ja wieder das Kühlkonzept von dem Server, das heißt, die kalte Luft kommt
hier von der Seite an und kann hier durch den Kühler durchströmen und dadurch, dass
der Kühler länglich sitzt, kann er eben auf der kompletten Länge genutzt werden, hier
kann es auch sehr gut durch die RAM-Module durchströmen, also so ist es rein thermisch
einfach besser, kann hier direkt auch vorne durch die Spannungswandler, hier und dahinter
durch die Spannungswandler, also einfach thermisch gesehen ist das so rotiert, mit diesem Kühlkonzept,
mit diesem Tunnel, die bessere Lösung.
Ansonsten gibt es hier noch so eine Hitzetestkammer, nenne ich das ganze mal, also da ist quasi
ein Heiz-Element unten drin, wo die die Innergriffe in dem Testsystem künstlich anheben können,
zum Beispiel 45 Grad Celsius und können dann so schwierigere Bedingungen für ihren Server
schaffen, um sicherzustellen, dass er auch, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel mal im schlimmsten
Fall die Klimaanlage ausfallen würde oder was auch immer, dass die Server dann in jedem
Fall, egal was passiert, immer noch weiter laufen.
Wenn die CPU dann vielleicht runter taktet, nicht ganz so schlimm, aber der Server ist
nicht ausgefallen.
Interessant fand ich übrigens auch dieses 3D-gedruckte Teil, hier kommt ein Anemometer
rein, das ist ein Messgerät, um die Luftstrom- bzw. die Luftmenge messen zu können, sowas
haben wir auch mal konzentriert, das heißt, lüft da vorne hin und dann einfach checken,
passt das, was der Hersteller angibt, kommen da wirklich 50 Kubikmeter die Stunde raus
oder sind es vielleicht auch nur 25, weil das kommt anscheinend auch häufiger mal vor,
das ist nur für 5 Kopfleute.
Alles in-house getestet, wir haben ja die Lüfter-Testanlage sowieso schon gesehen,
wo man dann schaut, halten die überhaupt über die angegebene Lebensdauer durch oder
vielleicht doch nicht und dementsprechend passen sie dann auch die Produkte eben an,
die sie verwenden.
Und hier wird dann wie gesagt einfach nur geschaut, dass so ein Server auch wenn mal
ein Problem in der Klimaanlage bestehen sollte, das normalerweise natürlich nicht der Fall
ist, aber dass dann so ein Server auch zuverlässig weiter funktioniert.
Hetzner hat ja im Normalfall keine wassergekühlten Server, trotzdem haben wir den hier gefunden,
den verwendet Hetzner, um Netzteile zu testen, weil hier ist ein AMD Threadripper drauf und
ihr alle wisst, wenn man den mal vor allem manuell übertaktet, da geht einiges, was
die Leistungsaufnahme betrifft und wenn man dann einfach mal schauen kann, kann das Netzteil
2D Last, keine Ahnung, 500, 600, 700 Watt, Threadripper eignet sich perfekt dafür.
Wir sind durch mit unserem Besuch bei Hetzner, war mega interessant, ich habe vorher noch
nie gesehen, wie so ein komplettes Data Center aufgebaut ist, deswegen Kühlung, alle, die
da waren, es war mega interessant, ich hoffe für euch auch, damit verabschieden, bis dahin,
ciao.
Was ich cool fand, es hat sich ja noch ein bisschen zu dem unterscheiden, was ich so
gesehen habe bisher, aber es macht halt auch Sinn bei so einem Anbieter.
Ja und jetzt auch mal eine Runde, es ist sehr laut, Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat, wenn
ihr euch 20 Euro Startgut haben für die Hetznerklausel sichern wollt, gucken wir mal als nächstes
den Gedudel anmachen.
Was gucken wir uns als nächstes an, erstmal YouTube, YouTube darf jetzt nochmal uns was
vorschlagen, 1500 Meter Headshot, ok Battlefield, zeig mal her, ah ja, natürlich, Obvious,
da hinten ist er, ich sehe den Gegner sofort, komplett klar, dass da hinten ein Gegner war,
was sonst, so, also was schauen wir uns hier jetzt an, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
also was schauen wir uns hier jetzt an, wir müssen uns doch chibaten lassen, wöchentlicher
Chibate von Level Cap, Level Cap muss uns chibaten, wichtig, Level Cap Chibate, im Moment
ist es Today in Gaming, sonst gucken wir doch immer Week in Gaming an, ach Quatsch, Specialists
werden in Battlefield drin bleiben, das ist das womit ihr Geld verdienen wollt, unter
anderem, warte mal, von wann ist das, 13 der Mal, da gibt es aber mittlerweile bestimmt
schon neue, das wird, Zeck, Week in Gaming, was ist das an, an, dann sollten wir uns lieber
das angucken, wo ist Week in Gaming, ich muss mich chibaten lassen, Alter, egal, wir gucken
uns das trotzdem, also da wird nichts passieren, ich habe diese Umfrage auch gesehen, da wird
nichts passieren, das einzige, das höchste, was DICE macht bei Specialists für Battlefield
2042 ist, dass sie eventuell das zusätzliche Kit bisschen beschränken, also dass du beispielsweise
jetzt mit Limb Assault keinen Kettenwerfer nehmen kannst oder so, aber selbst da, die
wollen mit den Specialists Geld verdienen, und Chet sagt, ich war mal Lidl Kaufland mal
im Rechenzentrum, da stehen Schiffsturbinen als Notstromaggregat und wenn die anlaufen
muss, die Gebäudewand hinter denen stehen rausklappen, ok, so krass habe ich das noch
nicht gesehen, was Stromausfall geht, also ich kenne das, ich kenne das zum Beispiel
mit einem Dieselmotor, dass du eine USB hast, die das dann kurz überbrückt, bis der Dieselmotor
angeworfen ist, und was ich auch schon gesehen habe, sind mechanische USBs, ich weiß nicht,
wie ich das anders beschreiben soll, habt ihr schon mal eine mechanische USB gesehen,
das ist ein Gewicht, was sich im Kreis dreht, und dadurch, dass es, keine Ahnung, ich sage
jetzt mal irgendwas, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie viel es genau sind, das sind dann irgendwie
300 Kilo, die sich im Kreis drehen, und dadurch, dass sich das 300 Kilo quasi im Kreis dreht,
hat es ja eine gewisse Rotationsmoment, quasi, den es, den, so, und das heißt, wenn dann
der Strom ausfällt, Kreiselgrind, genau, das heißt, wenn dann der Strom ausfällt, dann
geht das Gewicht quasi noch zwei, drei Runden, oder wie auch immer, dreht sich das weiter,
weil der Strom ist ja weg, das bedeutet, man hat wirklich mechanisch diese Energie für,
keine Ahnung, drei, vier Sekunden, bis der Diesel hochgefahren ist, macht man kaum noch,
gibt's aber noch.
Ja, Players demanden immer viel, wenn der Tag lang ist, DICE muss gucken, dass es ins
Gesamtkonzept noch reinpasst, ich hätte es auch schöner gefunden, hätten wir klassische
Klassen gehabt, oder zumindest die Option auf klassische Klassen, aber, also, ich mein's
nicht in Portal, aber zum Beispiel ein klassischer Battlefield 3 Assault, den's ja bugged in
der Beta wohl zu spielen gab, kennt ich cooler, aber gut, ich mein, jetzt haben sie sich dafür
entschieden und jetzt sollte man auch gucken, dass man jetzt nicht was ändert, nur weil
die Spieler rumschreien, aber es dann überhaupt nicht mehr zum Gesamtkonzept passt.
Ja.
Ja, gut.
Ich glaube, das war tatsächlich ein ganz großer Bestandteil dieser Umfrage, um zu sehen,
nach diesem ganzen Aufschrei, den's überall gegeben hat, wie abgefuckt die Leute wirklich
sind.
Oh, da werden die Cheaters jetzt aber sicher sagen, nein, nein, dann, also, wenn die,
dann geh ich weg, dann hör ich auf.
Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Ah, neues Rootkit.
Neues Rootkit eingebaut, sehr gut.
Ah, da ist Rootkit am Start.
Yeah, jawoll.
Wird doch am Ende auch nichts bringen.
Es hat einen Grund, warum von Valorant eine komplett neue Art von Cheats ausgeht, nämlich
hardware-geschützte Cheats, die quasi Mouse-Inputs machen, die per Gefeg der Netzwerkkarte RAM-Sachen
auslesen und verarbeiten auf einem Microcontroller.
Leute, das ist, dass dieses Wettrennen Cheater und Anti-Cheat ist im Endeffekt kaum zu gewinnen.
Das Einzige, was hilft, ist, Custom-Server gut gewissenhaft, sag ich mal, moderiert,
das heißt nicht, dass man jeden bannen sollte, der gut spielt, sondern einfach, dass man
Leute hat, die drauf gucken.
Wie oft begegnet man Cheatern in Valorant vs. Warzone, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich spiele
beides nicht mal aktiv und Valorant habe ich ja nie gespielt.
Ja gut, Warzone, das stimmt schon, Warzone ist richtig im Arsch.
Hat es dich auch beunruhigt, dass es keinen Server-Browser gibt?
Ja, hat mich beunruhigt.
Wobei sie aber im Vorfeld, glaube ich, gesagt haben, dass einen geben wird, aber DICE erzählt
viel im Vorfeld, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ohne Server-Browser, ich sage es euch Leute, hat das Ding Skill-Best-Matchmaking.
Also das, wo alle gesagt haben, Max kann nicht sein.
Der zweite Beta-Tag, der dritte Beta-Tag war das ja quasi dann, das letzte, wo wir
mal gespielt haben, waren die Gegner deutlich schwitziger und tryhardiger als am Anfang.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendwie erst BMM gegriffen hat oder ob bloß noch die ganzen
Schwitzer am Start waren, also ich hoffe nicht, ja dann werden wir sehen, dass das auch nichts
bringt.
Was bedeutet SBMM?
SBMM steht für Skill-Best-Matchmaking, also sprich, das Game versucht dich in eine Lobby
zu werfen, wo alle, ja so ungefähr auf deinem Level sind, was im Endeffekt auch das Gefühl
auf Dauer vermittelt, dass du kein Progress machst.
Also im Prinzip, im Prinzip ist es ganz einfach, Skill-Best-Matchmaking ist das, was sich public
0815, 0815 Kram sich anfühlen lässt, wie ranked, also ranked ist ja quasi der Inbegriff
von Skill-Best-Matchmaking, wenn du jetzt allerdings einen ranked Modus quasi unter
der Haube in normalem Public Kram hast.
Aber ohne, dass du deinen Rank irgendwie großartig siehst, wobei ich glaube, kann man nicht in
Warzone mittlerweile halbwegs sehen, gab es da nicht irgendwas in Warzone, wo man gucken
kann, was man für einen internen Rank hat?
Oder war das eine Third-Party-Seite?
Das ging doch irgendwie, ich habe schon eine ganze Weile Warzone immer gespielt.
Ja, Battlelog fand ich auch gut, ich habe Battlelog erst richtig abgehatet, aber nach
kurzer Zeit fand ich Battlelog cool, weil ich finde, es gibt doch eigentlich nichts
besseres, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, für so eine Social-Community-Seite wie Battlelog
mit Foren, Freundeslisten, Spieler, Clans und dann letztendlich auch Server-Suche, als
das in einem Browser zu machen.
Dafür benutzt man den Browser, wofür er da ist.
Also, war das sinnvoll, ja, das ist ein bekannter Bug mit den Battlefield-3-Klassen, ja, das
ist ein bekannter Bug mit den Battlefield-3-Klassen, wo kehrt es, das ist bestimmt Sponsor-Placement.
Das braucht Ray-Tracing.
Ja, der Graf kommt eh nicht zum UV-OP raus, es kommt als doppelte Kostas wieder, naja,
Grafikkarte easy.
Oh nein, ernsthaft, das Ghost Recon Battle Royale, das hat die Welt gebraut, ah das passt,
das ist wunderbar, ist das nicht Ubisoft, ist das nicht Ubisoft, hatte Ubisoft nicht
desanı snail, nicht dieolin vital sind, nicht die Marin & M College die sind anderem Battle
Royale gestartet, der nach 2 Tagen keine Saw-Mbox gespielt.
Äh wie hieß das denn.
Hyper Scandinaysasgur...
8 Take
gucken oh das ist ja unglaublich beliebt halb wahnsinn hyperskate season 3 haben wir sogar
in overwhelmingly negative reaction unfortunately it looks like the aim is already facing delays
it was scheduled to have a closed playtest who cares
alter ubisoft gave no reason for the delay frontlines will offer a hundred and two player
battles with yes sind drei zuschauer bei zwei streamern die gucken wir haben wahrscheinlich
ihren stream gegenseitig auch und andere noch sein eigenem
16 square kilometers the game doesn't have a release date at launch it'll support all
platforms aside from the nintendo switch now before we get to our final store today i'm happy
to announce that battlefield friends is returning neve's gaming just announcing their turn of
the beloved animation series it's been m.i.a. for years and sorely missed the entire time
battlefield friends war geil i'll have it linked below battlefield friends are really
poggers it takes two has passed three million units sold its developer hazel light studio says the
milestone is humbling and heartwarming but battlefield friends were cool by the way ich
habe den hazard zone reveal noch gar nicht noch gar nicht gesehen hält mich gerade auf
official trailer ok marsch auf act youtube act so einfach kann es sein
ok gucken wir uns das mal ich habe es noch nicht gesehen also was ich von hazard zone weiß ist
dass sie explizit immer 35.000 mal gesagt haben nein es ist kein bettel royal so schauen wir mal
ditze
da kommt man auch immer so ein bunker raus stells das am start
es ist warum sorry leute warum sind die soldaten in diesen trailer immer so unglaublich ppega im
kopf sieht schon leise aus sich triffes das pornhub back up oder was ist da drauf
und die pence links oder was wird was wird die secure ok ich habe null verstanden was ist
darum ok also was ich jetzt verstanden habe ist es ist ein obje also ich rate da jetzt mal es ist
ein objektiv basierter modus wo man irgendwelche festplatten capturen muss und es gibt teams die
wollen einen davon abhalten und es gibt teams oder wahrscheinlich sollen alle teams die festplatten
capturen und nur ein team kann das halt machen wisst ihr was ich richtig cool finde als erstes
mir anfällt es ist endlich mal den modus wo man sich fokussieren kann auf vierer squads vierer squads ist finde ich optimale größe
vier leute kriegt man immer irgendwie zusammen ich hoffe auch dass genau wd wd und sie geht die brauchen
natürlich auch ein team also das finde ich nicht schlecht ob das jetzt natürlich gut ankommt sei
mal dahingestellt sonderlich competitive wird der modus dann wahrscheinlich nicht sein das wird
wahrscheinlich eher so einen mal gucken ich kann es mir ja mal schauen mal schauen mal gucken ich habe
jetzt das erste mal gesehen habe ich keine ahnung kann kein plan von
ach so ich kann ja nicht mal klein machen
ist mit pve und max 24 spay er pve mit bots oder was mit bots ist das eher so ein bisschen
hand handshow down mäßig dann oder wir müssen in battlefield friends trailer angucken ja
battlefield friends jawoll beste das habe ich so gern geguckt zu battlefield 3 zeiten
der noob der pro ist auch noch am start
das ist der typ das die beste folge ist auch voran mit dem messer das ganze gegner team
out new battlefield no thanks no thanks what are you talking about i mean do without me
what about your squad what about them what about playing the objective what about it what
happened to you kid i'll tell you what happened i'm over it man look i've jeep stuffed renazu team
they've got wingsuits now da bin ich ja mal gespannt das war im organ als das
originale battlefield war mega lustig die anderen sind auch am start da bin ich mal
gespannt das dauert noch einen monat noch dauert noch einen monat 19 naja ok ja doch
dauert noch einen monat noch einmal hätten wir schon gespielt aber mir ist lieber es
kommt weniger verbackt raus in den monat geht's los best alda best best so kurz ausgeflippt
weiter geht's gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an ja schon seit 25 jahren ne seit drei jahren
oder so was ist das bei strikes was soll ich mir da angucken zeigt mal her kann man das
bestimmt rick rolled oder sowas jetzt was was why new cars kipfel ist das der elch test
es juckt mich überhaupt nicht ihr wisst autos interessieren mich null wenn mich autos interessieren
würden könnte ich jeden sonntag 90 videos am stück gucken freust du dich auf 20 42 trotz
der beta ja mache ich weil ich habe gemerkt seitdem die beta off ist ich habe mich jetzt
schon paar mal dabei erwischt als ich gedacht habe ach ich würde doch ganz gerne mal einloggen
und ein paar runden spielen also so schlecht können sie es nicht gemacht haben auch wenn
das spiel wirklich viele probleme hat stimmt ab wann können die vorbesteller starten seck
heute ist ja wirklich schlimm meine güte
so ultimate edition also wann geht's los play standard compare editions ja gold edition
am zwölften das heißt es sind weniger als 30 tage
da kommt eigentlich das azubi wieder ich muss das heute fertig machen ich weiß ich weiß
ich habe guck mal leute mein letztes video das ist über eine woche her wird mir wieder
zeit ja wobei die letzten videos wirklich relativ gut angekommen sind muss man sagen
wie hier sind davor es schwankt immer so ein bisschen so schon mal ein bisschen größer
manche sachen sind nicht so spannend aber kann man abkühlen ich denke mal schon ich
denke schon dass man abkühlen kann die wollen ja dass du mehr geld ausgibst die samtnets
sind auch richtig premium poc glaube ich selbst gemacht welche samtnets sind gut die hier
die letzten also ich muss sagen diese kekse die ich hier hab als samtbatches eignen sich
auch wunderbar für samtnets und den mit dem hut und dem mlg joint auch nicht verkehrt
mein profilbild bräuchte man wieder ein update vielleicht lasse ich mir ja auch eins machen
in dem style hier oder man aber echt habe jetzt ja eine das die das echt gut hinbekommen
hat ok schauen wir mal so also was können wir uns das nächste angucken touchscreens
things that's pretty quiet case experts react wir haben jetzt genug battlefield stels geguckt
oder habt ihr auch diese werbung bekommen ich mir wurde das video heute morgen empfohlen
aber jetzt müsst ihr euch mal bekommen bekommt ihr auch diese werbung gerade ich hab letztens
auf twitter habe ich bekommen und es ist die typische scheißwerbung die dir was zeigt
was nichts mit dem game zu tun hat es ist es ist so ätzend oder es ist auch noch so
scheiße wahrscheinlich das gelb das gucken wir uns jetzt an wie scheiße das game ist
das interessiert mich das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur richtig scheiße wenn ich das hier
schon sehe warum sind alle mobile games der gleiche scheiß also was ich hier auf dem ersten
bild schon sehe ist im game currency die übrigens ein bisschen aussieht wie zelda rupees aber
dem sei es drei verschiedene in game currencies sehe ich hier oben schon ich sehe ein absolut
dummes identitätsloses aufbau gameplay städte bauen sich andere in game bei mechaniken so
eine scheiße mann warum sind alle mobile games der gleiche dreck
warum wir die lizenz überhaupt her gekriegt
naja geld was sonst
ich sag euch toll gehen wird im grab rumdrehen ich mein der sohn der sohn von ihm fand ja
schon die filme nicht gut im nachhinein und wenn er sowas sehen würde der wird der würde
nicht der wird sie nicht rumdrehen im grab da würde rauskommen und die klatschen er
warum ist der chat russisch
ok ich predicte jetzt mal was ich predicte jetzt mal was das das hier wird es ganz selten
geben weil das sieht ja zumindest mal ansatzweise nach einem spiel aus ich wette mit dir das
einzige was du in diesem spielmodus machen kannst ist hier auf den knopf drücken zum
feuern und oder hier zum die fände mehr mehr gibt es mehr gibt es nicht
das ist ja das schlechteste model aller zeiten all das sieht ja schlecht aus
ist das game ernsthaft installiert wirklich lull also ich bin ja auch zumindest kleine
herr der ringe fan aber das game würde ich im traum nicht dran denken mit den scheiß
zu installieren
die nutellaschnitte fällt mir nichts ein nein das ist nicht gut
sagt man sagt mir irgendwas net ease net ease was haben die denn sonst warte mal sagt mir
irgendwas irgendwas sage ich china chinesen auf jeden fall was haben die denn sonst noch
was warcraft 3 liga ich weiß irgendwas irgendwas sagt mir net ease im hinterkopf und nichts
sonderlich positives
naja egal schauen wir mal
eko krass und wisst ihr was auch schlimm ist dass diese ganzen mobile games auch immer
der gleiche das ist so ein typisches crappy mobile game cover die dinger sehen alle so
aus immer immer der gleiche nicht sagende scheiß trecks comic look ich ihr wisst ihr
merkt vielleicht ich bin übelst ich hasse diese sorte games alle ich könnte auch immer
der gleiche irgendein typ der rum schreit auf dem cover immer dieser billige gleiche
scheiß und es verkauft sich einfach auch
das muss was offizieller sein die haben den soundtrack drin aber das ist nicht das
original die voice actors hatten überhaupt keinen bock
After an uncomfortably intense few minutes we can choose a faction, there are ten to choose
so far has been acceptable if a little bit sultry i don't know which faction passive buff
is best so i just go with gondor your ring what does it look like damn game at least buy me dinner
first so we design our ring because every player has a ring of power das ergibt egal a lot of
herr der ringe lore interessiert ja bei dem spiel wahrscheinlich nicht
the design is total fluff and doesn't matter at all it's just surface level junk to make you feel
invested and then we meet gandalf who is voiced you are awake excellent it seems you were
with no chance at all to get our bearings we are thrown into a battle well i say we are thrown in we
are there versucht der versucht ja schon ein bisschen wie das wie das original zu klingen
wobei man ja wobei wobei ich ja eins lernen muss ich ich kannte ja also ich habe das damals als
im kino geguckt habe habe ich auf deutsch geguckt ich habe die aber mittlerweile auch schon auf
englisch mal geschaut mir ist ja aufgefallen dass die dass wir mordor komplett falsch aussprechen
ja wenn man sich das im original anhört die sagen ja ich kann es gar nachmachen mordor
sagt ihr eher wer auch immer das schafft so auszusprechen ja level up das darf natürlich
nicht fehlen typischer mobile crap was zum teufel hat warum will gollum meinen fake ring das ergibt
überhaupt keinen sinn natürlich natürlich auch verschiedene raritätsstufen ganz wichtig dass
die leute schön gampeln ja wie kann man so eine scheiße spielen man fällt euch auf fällt
also eine sache was alle diese mobile spiele in dieser art diese aufbau spielen was die was
sie gemein haben ist die besitzen kein gameplay habt ihr irgendwas außer diesen kurzen ausstehen
am anfang wo man wahrscheinlich auch nur 1 2 eigens klicken darf habt ihr bisher irgendwas
gesehen was gameplay ist das hier ist ja kein gameplay das ist eine übersichtskarte wo nichts
passiert das sieht aus dass es bestimmt alles unity oder so ich meine die kloppen sich hier
aber du machst ja nichts
das war es jetzt oder was krass ist das gameplay aller zeiten alter also wenn das wenn das
kein anderer als ist das gelb zu spielen hoi hoi hoi was macht der kelle überhaupt da
zum
Fuck! Städtebau ist auch mit drin, was sonst?
Warum sind alle Mobile Games der gleiche Shit?
Ich fass es nicht!
So schlecht!
Der gleiche Scheiß, Mann!
Ich guck mir das Video nicht komplett an.
Das ist alles der gleiche.
Ja, natürlich!
Natürlich brauchst du auch noch 50.000 Ressorts
und was auch nicht fehlen darf,
wettig mit euch ist der Ingame Store,
der auch fünf verschiedene Currencies anbietet
und der Trick des Jahrtausends, den alle,
aber auch wirklich alle,
Mobile Games verwenden.
Sie zeigen dir auf der Startseite was,
was total teuer ist,
wo dann dran steht 15.000 Ingame Gold
oder irgendwie sowas
und unten drunter steht dann
jetzt aber 500% reduziert
und dann siehst du eine Seite weiter was,
was fast das gleiche Item ist,
aber nur einen Bruchteil davon kostet.
So dieses Fake Value für Items.
Das machen alle Mobile Games.
Und dann denkst du dir,
wie ich kann für 15.000 Gold
den, keine Ahnung,
was auch immer kaufen
und aber ich kann für nur 500
irgendwie super Item kaufen,
was fast genauso gut ist
und dann machen das die Leute,
weil sie denken,
boah, da spare ich ja richtig Geld.
Dabei ist das eigentlich
kompletter Schwachsinn.
Das kostet ja nichts.
Diese Items haben keinen
wirklichen Wert dahinter.
Man konnte sich bei Diablo 2,
Diablo 2 hat so richtig angefangen,
wo man in-game Items auf Ebay verkauft hat.
Hab ich damals auch gemacht, muss ich sagen.
Auch wenn das gegen die TOS war,
aber ihr meint gut,
ich verjährt mittlerweile.
Und da hatte aber Diablo 2 Items
oder Charakter,
hatten ja noch einen gewissen Wert dahinter.
Da wurde viel Zeit reingesteckt,
um den Charakter dahin zu bringen
oder um die Items zu Farmen.
Also China gefarmte Items
haben noch einen gewissen Wert dahinter,
weil es unglaublich viel Zeit braucht,
die zu farmen,
unter den normalen Bedingungen.
Deswegen haben wir diese ganzen Games
auch immer irgendeinen Zeitfaktor drin.
Zum Beispiel,
rekrutiere neue Einheiten,
dauert aber 5 Real-Life-Tage oder so was.
Kommt bestimmt auch gleich noch.
Aber diese Items hier
haben einfach nichts dahinter, gar nichts.
Weil du kannst ja noch nicht mal
was damit machen.
Ja, kaufst du dir in einem MMO Gold
von einem China-Farmer,
kannst du dich ausrüsten
und das MMO spielen wenigstens.
Aber hier gibt es nichts zu spielen.
Oder kommt wahrscheinlich nichts mehr.
Ja, das ist...
Ah ja, aufleveln deine Helden natürlich auch noch.
Wichtig ist,
in diesen Spielen immer,
du musst permanent größere Zahlen
und füllende Fortschrittsbalken sehen.
Da stehen die Leute drauf.
Bis jetzt habe ich noch keinen Gameplay gesehen.
Ihr füllende, füllende Balken, ganz wichtig.
Ach, man muss nur 24 Stunden warten.
Ich wette mit euch,
ich kann mir einfach In-Game-Currency kaufen
und den Wartebalken überspringen.
Ah, yes.
Ah, okay, Sekunde, Sekunde, Sekunde, was?
Ach ja, das ist ja,
das ist ja fast,
das ist ja fast geschenkt.
Einfach nur 100, 100 Pfund aus.
Was sind das? 120, 120 Euro oder so?
Keine Ahnung.
First time plus 23.000, okay.
Das gebetet die Leute,
zu sagen, ich gebe 200 Pfund aus.
Wie schlecht das auch noch aussieht
in der eigentlichen,
nennen wir es mal, Gameplay-Perspektive.
Das sieht ja noch nicht mal gut aus
für Handy-Games.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das sieht noch nicht mal,
das ist Warcraft 3 Niveau von,
das ist Warcraft 3 Units,
original Warcraft 3 Units.
Die original Warcraft 3 Units,
nicht etwa irgendwie die, die, die.
Guckt euch mal an, das Schild.
Da waren aber bloß 5 Polygone für übrig.
Sieht aus wie ein TS-Game, ja.
Ah, yes, alles klar, alles klar.
Die haben wirklich die Lizenz,
sonst könnten die das alles
nicht so aussehen lassen.
Alles klar, obvious, obvious.
Oh, das ist so ein,
das ist so ein Rots Mobile Games, alter.
Das ist wirklich der absolute
Bodensatz an Spielen.
Und Spieler, beides.
Warum ist hier unten übrigens,
warum, das muss jetzt,
ach, das ist, das ist der Ring.
Ich hab gedacht,
das ist der neuen Live-Hot Button
oder sowas,
wo du dann passen kannst.
So schlecht.
Nö.
Das ist übrigens,
das ist, das ist, das ist normal
für diese Games.
Weil Gameplay ist teuer.
Weil du, du musst hier
irgendwelche,
du musst Maps designen,
du musst Zeug bauen,
das ist easy, das ist easy, ja.
Und füllende Balken
und größer werdende Zahlen,
das müllen die Leute einfach.
Gameplay, wer braucht denn Gameplay
schon in einem Spiel?
Alter.
War klar.
Übrigens, der Grund,
warum es so viele
Ingame-Währungen gibt, ist,
weil Ingame-Währungen
abstrahieren quasi echtes Geld.
Also du denkst dir nichts bei,
wenn irgendwo dran steht,
das kostet 5, 5 Gems oder so.
Oder das kostet 500 Gems.
Aber wenn da dransteht würde,
das kostet 2,50 Euro,
dann werden die meisten Leute sagen,
nee, warum sollte ich das denn machen?
Aber wenn da dran steht,
500 Gems,
da denkt man sich,
oh na na, kann man ja mal machen.
Was bist du sehend?
Ein dreckiges,
räudiges Mobile-Game,
was sackt.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen,
ganz viele Leute machen
so quasi diesen Standardfehler.
Die nehmen das, rechnen das zusammen
und sagen, ah, okay,
und da bekomme ich ja quasi,
für jedes mehr bekomme ich ja quasi dann,
also wird es dann immer billiger.
Und wenn ich es kaufe,
dann kriege ich es noch doppelt.
Also ganz viele Leute lassen sich
chibaten, das hier zu kaufen.
100 pro.
Das ist ja der Trick bei solchen Games.
Das ist ein anderer psychologischer Trick,
weil du denkst,
der größte Pack ist der beste Wert.
Also du kaufst einen großen Pack.
Dann,
auch wenn du später quitten willst,
denkst du,
naja,
ich habe Geld verwendet,
ich muss jetzt quitten.
Und die gesunkenste Kosten-Fallacy
sinkt die Klauze in dir
und das Spiel hat dich.
Aber hey,
vielleicht willst du nicht
100 Euro fallen lassen.
Das ist okay.
Du kannst Aragorn kaufen,
ein neuer Commander,
für 99 Pents.
Ist das nicht schön?
Das ist ziemlich teuer.
Und nachdem du den 100-Pack-Pack
in deinem Gesicht hast...
Ja, das ist genau das,
das ist genau das,
die zeigen dir erst was teures
und jetzt zeigen sie dir was günstiges.
Und dann sagst du,
ach ja,
das könnte ich ja kaufen.
Das fühlt sich wie ein Bargain an.
Ja, Chet,
ihr habt recht,
wir müssen uns nicht fertig gucken.
Aber das ist der Inbegriff
von reudischen Kack-Mobile-Games, Alter.
So dermaßen Müll,
das ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Und ich verstehe nicht,
warum es so viele Leute...
Ich meine,
die müssen ja viele Leute
drauf reinfallen.
Wenn da nicht die Leute
drauf reinfallen,
gäbe es den Kram ja nicht.
Beste.
Das gucken wir zum Abschluss heute.
Wirklich.
Das sind nicht Kinder.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wisst ihr,
also wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich sind das auch Kiddies,
die da spielen.
Aber wahrscheinlich sind das eher
Leute,
so die ultra-mega-casual-Spieler.
So von der Hausfrau
bis zu Leuten, bis zu Boomer-Leuten
in meinem Alter,
die Herr der Ringe noch geil finden.
Es mag sicherlich
die ein oder anderen
Mobile-Games geben,
die tatsächlich was taugen.
Aber nope, nope, nope.
Nochmal Pains-Champ, völlig.
Nein.
Ja, okay, weiter.
Wir gucken jetzt ein bisschen
Smart-Home-Stells.
Das hier.
10 Impressive Home Automations
from around the world.
Da ist bestimmt wieder
Zeug dabei,
was ich auch nachbauen will.
Beste.
Many of you sent in
your automations
and I was blown away
by how creative you are.
Blown away.
There are so many things
I would...
War das Kassetten?
MonkaS?
...away by how creative...
Boomer-Clap.
...of you are.
There are...
Wisst ihr überhaupt noch,
was das ist?
Ja, doch.
Wahrscheinlich die meisten
schon hier
gute Musik hier am Start.
Aber, äh, naja.
Schockt.
Oh, big brain.
Habt ihr's gesehen?
Die Tür geht automatisch auf
wenn der Hund da vorsitzt,
wie auch immer.
Das interessiert mich,
was er gemacht hat.
Na, das hab ich...
Das hab ich schon öfters
gesehen.
Nee.
Also, was ich jetzt
gecatched habe, ist,
er geht rein
und das Licht geht an.
Das, äh, ist jetzt
nicht so beeindruckend.
Ja, okay.
Da musst du aber
einen gewissen Pepofettgrad
aufweisen,
dass die Bewegungs-,
dass die, ähm,
Vibrationssensoren merken,
dass du da vorumläufst.
Ach, jetzt sehe ich das.
Der läuft von da nach da
und dann wandert das Licht mit.
Oh, das ist feifett.
Die Sache ist nur die,
wozu braucht man das?
Warum kann man nicht einfach
überall hell machen?
Also, ich mein,
wo ist der Sinn davon,
dass es hier heller ist
als da?
Ich mein,
es ist eine geile Idee,
aber der Sinn
erschließt sich mir
nicht wirklich.
Um in dem Video zu erscheinen,
weil es geht.
Ja, verstehe ich,
verstehe ich schon.
Ihr wisst,
ich mach auch viel,
weil es geht.
Aber gerade in der Küche
könnte man einfach
hier komplett hell machen
oder noch besser noch
auch an der Decke hell machen
und gut ist.
Es ist toll.
Jetzt kann man es besser sehen,
während man kocht oder
wenn man...
Es ist toll.
Jetzt kann man es besser sehen,
während man kocht oder
wenn man...
Es ist toll.
Jetzt kann man es besser sehen,
während man kocht oder
wenn man...
Also, wenn du das hier hell machst
und das ein bisschen dimmst,
das spart so gut
wie keinen Strom.
Die Top-Drawer sind auch geöffnet.
Die Lichter sind aus Ikea
und sind mit diesem
30 Watt-Driver.
Alles ist mit SmartThings
mit einem Web-Core
für die Logis verbunden.
Ihh,
SmartThings,
was ist denn das für eine
ekligte Sprache?
Ist das wie man
in SmartThings
Scripts macht?
Das ist ja...
Das ist, wenn man das
schlechteste
aus Visual Basic
und Zeug zusammen mischt.
Oder was ist das?
Eingerückt,
schlüsselt,
if, then und dann
abgeschlossen mit
Simicolon, meine Güte,
weil du das dann überlegt.
Ich hab also
der einzige Ort,
in dem ich
einen Motion-Sensor,
keinen Vaporation-Motion-Sensor
hab,
ist,
ich hab im Softwareraum
einen stehen,
wenn ich die Tür aufmach,
geht's Licht automatisch an.
Soll er nicht smooth
sehen die Lines hier
aber nicht aus,
muss er danach
nochmal abschmiegeln.
Die Fettes sind die,
äh, Motion-Sensor
gibt's von klein bis groß.
Naja.
Kann man machen,
braucht man aber
eigentlich nicht.
Man könnte nämlich,
man könnte nämlich,
also was ich viel
sinnvoller finde,
man kann das einfach
an eine
an eine Steckdose anschließen,
die misst,
was der 3D-Drucker
verbraucht
und wenn der aufhört
zu heizen,
braucht er weniger.
Und dann macht man's
einfach so,
wenn er länger
als fünf Minuten,
äh,
quasi unter
einem gewissen Level ist,
dann schaltet man ihn
einfach aus.
Dann geht nämlich
alles aus,
es kühlt weiter ab.
Ich würde es nicht direkt
ausschalten,
weil der 3D-Drucker
noch heiß ist
und den Lüfter,
der drei abgeryft.
Naja.
noch nicht gemacht aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das on-stream machen sollte ich
weil wir haben nicht eine steckdose geflasht die anderen gehen genauso
die okto print habe ich auch worauf haustest du ein homo system auf dem low
power inter x86 sport
can we just appreciate how futuristic this is
massiv futuristic announced throughout your house
this something has been 3d printed
this is something you would have seen in like back to the west mit nachschauen ob
das fertig ist naja das ist tatsächlich nicht so optimal weil so ein 3d druck
je nachdem was du hast kann ja mal auch von vier stunden bis keine ahnung 30
stunden gehen also ich finde es gar nicht verkehrt wenn
es einfach anmachst und laufen lässt und dann sagt sie durch so lange es halt
nicht nachts nachts durch sagt
und i've been wanting a 3d printer for a long time but this might finally push me
over the edge to get one and a charmander looks pretty awesome
next up is an automation from andrew it's a mix of old school with the new
technology
dasselbe ist cassette tapes have an nfc tag in them
a phone it's sort of a good idea
das ist eine big brain idee das finde ich cool echo device
i think this is really creative it's a great way to take a test
coole idee repurpose it and i'm sure it took a while to set up also das ist
wirklich eine richtig gute idee
das ist übrigens richtig gut platziert ihr das aber
das ist das ist das überhaupt aber
das ist eine gute idee wenn man wirklich kassettensammlungen hat ich hab so was
nicht mehr aber
wenn man wirklich kassettensammlungen hat und das quasi mit digitalen sachen
verbinden ist das wirklich
eine gute idee
but you can't put a price on that cool factor
andrew is using home assistant that scans an nfc tag and plays music using
alexa media player
it was created as a blueprint so it should be really easy to implement if you want to do
this yourself
nfc tags are so useful and inexpensive
ja das stimmt nfc tags kosten wirklich bloß ein paar cent
also nfc tags kann ich prinzipiell nur empfehlen
ich habe in barton nfc tag
das habe ich ja hier im video schon mal gezeigt
klo
acht jahre premium klo
schau mal das neueste video von
stunder
warum
was um was gehts da
ach wegen der mit dem source code leak
guck mal hier ist ein nfc tag
sieht jetzt vielleicht nicht stylisch aus aber
man erkennt das
äh zeige ich das überhaupt im video wo ich dann
nfc tagge
ich zeige das wo habe ich das denn gezeigt
habe ich das auf twitter gezeigt
nfc
ja
alter twitter video ist so pains champ
guck zu euch an
ich hoffe die qualität wird besser
jetzt spinnt er wieder rum
ja ich laber jetzt selbst dabei
guck mal das ist mein heizlüfter da hinten der ist an der remote schaltbaren
steckdose angeschlossen
und jetzt
ich weiß nicht wann ichs zeige irgendwann
twitter alter twitter ist wirklich so schlecht von dem video her
ich laber jetzt noch ein bisschen pass auf so
nfc tag
und jetzt einfach
handy dran halten
detected
und jetzt geht der lüfter an
und jetzt handy wieder dran halten und zack lüfter geht aus
und jetzt
habe ich auf dem klo warm
ohne dass ich auf
warum fokussiert das nicht
ohne dass ich an den heiz da gehen muss
kann ich einfach weil ich hab immer ein handy immer dabei
ja genau
also dafür sind nfc tags wirklich top und das kostet keine ahnung
5 cent so ein nfc tag
also nfc tags sind wirklich extrem
poggers
um nicht zu sagen poggers
warme stinkende luft nein die luft stinkt nicht weil mein klo ja ein
absauger hat
für
äh luft
ich denke mir weisegut hight nfc tags
und triggert nfc tags ist wirklich nice
wenn du nur die dinger reagieren immer wieder so träge ob man muss
das genau an die stelle hat ja gut
das gebissen gewöhnung sagen ja das ist aber halt die sache an nfc nfc muss
wirklich genau dran halten
wie ist so die ct ich habe seit
vor 15 jahren oder so ein ct aber
oder noch länger 20 jahr 20 jahr
wahrscheinlich ct aber ich hab dir auch alle noch hier
ich habe eine komplette wand die ist gestapelt
bis zur mitte mit mit ct ist eigentlich könnte ich das mal wegschmeißen
halka queen led zeppelin
den ex automation ist von jacob who's from georgia in the u.s.a
und es ist ja gut zu zum glück ist nicht georgien
tornado warning from the national weather service
alerts are automatically throughout the house
tornado warning
for your area lights are flashing red and a custom noise
kakona
only kakona
which i thought was a nice touch
jacob is using the national weather service api to make rest calls
and get the data for his county and local zone
i'll link the guide on also merke kona gehts ja kaum
die idee ist aber gut stellt euch mal vor
ihr müsst mal ich würde bloß sicherstellen dass das
nicht irgendwie also ich würde es wirklich auch nur machen wenn das wenn
die wenn sich diese wetter wetter api wirklich sicher ist
so stell dir mal vor du kriegst du schläfst nachts und das ding sagt
achtung tornado incoming und dann passiert gar nix
custom sounds and mp3 was uploaded to the www folder
and it was referenced by calling the play media service
i used to live in texas and the tornado warnings would freak me out
i didn't want to get hit in the middle of the night when i was asleep
so if i were still there i would have definitely set something like this up
next up is a really unique automation from jaron in toronto
wie kriegt er die tür auf und zu der muster in den motor wahrscheinlich hinter
dem vorhangenden motor
the dogs are letting themselves out
this is next level
there's a motion sensor inside that's nice and low for the dog
then on the outside there's a pressure sensor mat
that way the dog can go all by themselves
the door also müssen nur sicherstellen dass da nix andere sitzt als ihr hund
only opens partially for the dog
and when the button is pressed the door opens all the way
or it can open using an echo device
if you cannot add a doggy door
hier oben ist ein motor dran
you cannot add a doggy door this is a creative way to let your dogs out
and i hope we continue to see more automated doors because i think they're so awesome
and i know it sounds lazy
but i would definitely use one especially if i was outside barbecuing
i can't open this is using a motor on the sliding door connected to a white
aber ich finde kinder so nervig
which is using e-wheeling to connect it all to the amazon echo
outside is this pressure mat
ah ok
and connected it to the door opener
this next automation is from george all the way from new zealand
picking up the playstation controller
aus new zealand
automatically turns on the tv and the computer down below i really like this automation because
it's so practical
und weiter was ist das problem?
i really like this
das check ich nicht der nimmt seinen ps5 controller und der fernseh geht an
ok
ist tatsächlich praktisch aber
unter pc ok
you don't have to go around looking for the tv remote or try to find the on button
ne ne ne man kann das schon aus sein eigenes land einstellen mit den tornadoes
ich würde aber auf jeden fall einstellen dass es
über 90 prozent wahrscheinlichkeit ist oder so
also ich würde nicht sagen sobald da irgendwas aufploppt weil ich hab kein bock dass das
ding also ich hätte kein bock
dass das ding mich nachts aufweckt
und ich denke fuck gleich fliegt mein haus weg und dann passiert gar nichts
computer in the dark george is using a xiaomi contact sensor connected to homekit
xiaomi
using a zigbee dongle and homebridge
then there are two integrations to get the pc and the tv connected to homebridge
of course you could use something like the eve contact sensor
ja das ist easy
that works natively
but homebridge is a great option if you want to use a lot more devices
hat er den sensor jetzt unten am controller dran hängen oder wie oder das ist ja auch
doof
with homekit the next automation is from sony in australia who set up a shower timer
they're using a lifex bulb that flashes after five minutes to know when it's time to finish
showering
then if the light is still on
und warum bleibt er nicht einfach so lange unter der dusch stehen wie er will
flash red after two more minutes
this is a great way to not waste water and to stay on schedule
especially since at the end of the shower timer the light turns off
that is commitment right there
but there is a workaround for the light to stay on longer
they're using a huge smart dimmer switch to turn on the light
but if someone holds down on the dimmer it will override the countdown and not
ah yes
obvious obvious
flash the lights
this was all done inside node red
that way it doesn't annoy anyone
das ist übrigens der grund warum ich node red nicht mag
viele schwören auf node red zum automatisieren von irgendwelchen abläufen aber ich finde
also ich persönlich
kann logik in source code viel einfacher lesen als diese komischen node red nodes
verdingste dinger da
countdown and not flash the lights
this was all done inside node red
that way it doesn't annoy anyone if they need extra time to get ready in the bathroom
and smart lights are such a great way to get notified and to stay on schedule like this automation
especially in the shower when you have limited options
next is an automation submitted by josiah over in tennessee
this is a goodbye
von den farben her ähnlich wie meine
bloß anders verteilt
goodbye animation
automation that is triggered by a voice command
it stops the morning music that might be playing
turns off all the smart lights and plugs
und macht den temperature on the thermostat to away
den vacuum an
robot vacuum
and arms the ring alarm system
das habe ich nicht das hat sowas habe ich sowas habe ich mal probiert sowas habe ich nicht
ich habe nur eine abends alles aus automatisierung
useful automation because it's doing so many things that you might forget when you're rushing out the door
and this automation is only using the amazon app
and you could do all of this if you're using a google assistant routine as well
if you're using a different security system also look at this cute little cat
the automation start happening and it's not even phased
it must be highly cultured in home automation
the last automation is from tim who has a house
die katz die hat sich einfach schon dran gewöhnt
die das ist aber es ist wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht cat approved
over in thailand with security automations
using the geofence and smart things
the outside gate opens when they are pulling up to their house
also the light turns on for five minutes
and then the gate closes after it's been open for three minutes
inside there are big febaro buttons and multi-purpose sensors on the door
gibt es eine lexer aus europa die nicht alle meine daten speichert? nope
if the door senses vibration late at night or if the button is pressed twice in a row
all the lights flash red
alter
the aotec siren goes off
and alerts are sent
alter da flippst du ja aus wenn das nachts passiert
these lights are intense and i would be out of there
stell dir mal vor
du schläfst und auf ach du scheiße mann
thanks to everyone who sent in automations
it's so much fun to see how you're using automations in your home
and if you want to send in an automation for a future video
gibt es eine kleine kamera für den türspion
ja so was gibt's
weiß aber nicht was sie taugen
außerdem ich wollte gerade sagen
eigentlich braucht er gar kein licht
der braucht ne benachrichtigung und dann holt er erst mal das gewehr unterm bett raus
das wir sind doch beide amis
as well as links and more info for everything in this video
i look forward to see if i get the m4 rausholen
alright that's the end
wait wait reid there's actually another one that just came in
oh really
well let's watch it then
hello reid my name is
pro
pro hubert
das ist doch ein anderer youtuber da in skamast oder?
this is something that works without internet it's a flick button
and when you press it it turns on my studio lights
i use for no particular reason
excellent super
ähm
paints chap
so ey das video wollte ich euch kurz zeigen
der typ ist next level was er mit led mit rgb led effekten und sowas macht
der kerl ist wirklich der wahnsinn
der übertreibt es der übertreibt es komplett
der hat auch ein video von seinem haus wie er da die rgb leds eingebaut hat
aber diesmal hat er das video kenne ich schon
hat er halloween decoration gemacht leute ich sag euch
also sowas habt ihr noch nicht gesehen dass das jemand daheim hat
also das ist wirklich der typ ist wirklich next level was licht effekte am haus angeht
guck mal
das hat er im garten
das hat er einfach im garten stehen
das ist so krass alter
ja ich würd's mir auch nicht ans haus bauen
wäre mir viel zu viel auffahren
aber grade bei amis
mit äh
die sind
die sind die
da ist halloween das ding schlechthin ist das mega geil und sowas selbst zu bauen ist schon anspruchsvoll
gut ich mein tagsüber siehts ein bisschen kacke aus muss man mal sagen
das geht eigentlich
110 dollar für ein ding ist absolut ordnung
erst mal kurz skippen
LED beste
wirst du gleich mal gucken wenn er zeigt was er für effekte hat also das ist echt next level
ich mein the fuck
ich find 110 euro pro projektor vollkommen in ordnung
ich meine
grade bei den amis wo es ja immer so ein bisschen der wettbewerb ist wer hat die coolere halloween ausstattung so du oder der nachbar oder der nächste nachbar
das bist du schon mal hier wirklich nummer eins mit
ja gut
wenn du wenn du nachts wenn du da rangehst siehst du es
es sieht halt ich mein nacht das sieht schon mega nice aus wenn man auch so halloween sieht
ja auch die kürbisse sind richtig cool ich meine tagsüber siehts halt kacke aus
ja auch die kürbisse sind richtig cool
ich finde die kürbisse auch richtig nice
jetzt zeigt er die kürbisse jetzt zeigt er die kürbisse die sind richtig geil
also das macht schon was her
ich würde es auch nicht ans haus machen aber an sich die idee und so das ist alles schon richtig nice
das wollte ich nicht gucken was passiert hier was bin ich da sehend
das ist alles vergilbte sachen wieder wieder ja gut was gucken wir uns als nächstes an gelbes pvc
den wollte ich mir kaufen den wollte ich mir kaufen das ist ein neuer so neuer sonoff switch zwei switche mit relays und im display
also ich sehe den sinn davon auch nicht mit der software die drauf ist
so youtube jetzt hast du so mal scheuze was ordentliches vorzuschlagen
das ist was für mich da kann ich flamen
aber ich hab mich eigentlich schon genug darüber ausgelassen
ich hab mir eigentlich schon genug darüber ausgelassen
Das Video war auch geil, TerraformingVenus, am Anfang sagte er, ja könnte einfacher sein
als man denkt und das restliche Video beschäftigt sich damit, dass es eigentlich nicht möglich
ist.
Das Kino kenne ich von ihm, das haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Ja irgendwie sind die YouTube Vorschläge, wie komme ich auf Amazon, YouTube Vorschläge
nicht so geil.
Einsamkeit von kurz gesagt, oh ne ich habe jetzt keinen Bock auf diepe Themen.
Die YouTube Empfehlungen sind wirklich kacke, das ist ja nichts dabei.
Gibt es noch How to Twitch Chat, das habe ich in letzter Zeit nix mal gesehen.
Beste Video von ihm ist immer noch, Kac W vs Lul W, bestes Intro, der Anfang ist schon
geil.
Wir gucken das jetzt nicht, aber der Anfang ist schon geil.
Die ersten 10 Sekunden könnte ich mir immer wieder angucken.
Leute ich sag so ungern, ich habe Hunger, ich glaube ich verpiss mich jetzt schon.
Zumal ich ja heute noch organisatorische Sachen erledigen muss und endlich mal das Video fertig
schnibbeln mit dem Azubi.
Was macht eigentlich der Frazier, spielt er wieder irgendwelche Weep Games?
Na heute glaube ich wird das nix mehr, weil dann müsste ich das Video ja fertig bekommen
bis 15 Uhr, dann wird wahrscheinlich nix.
Was macht denn der Frazier so, nix.
Wann war er zuletzt am Start?
Yesterday, Alter 6,5 Stunden, Aja ja Weep Game.
Das hat es ihm angetan.
MonkaS, habe ich eigentlich mal ein MonkaS Sound.
Wo habe ich mein MonkaS Sound, hier, schon die neuen Specialists in Battlefield 2042
gesehen.
Nee.
Wird aber wahrscheinlich nix sein, was man nicht eh schon gesehen hat.
Hat doch wahrscheinlich alles schon mal irgendwo geleakt gesehen im Vorfeld.
Was ist Kamera auf dem Memeboard, dass es wohl die rumschreien, als sie irgendwie ihr
360 NoScope auf Highrise gepackt haben.
Ja, den könnte man hosten, einer on.
Das ist immer noch der alte GIF-Player her, ja.
War das gerade das selbstgeschriebene Tool, ja, ja, ja, ja, das ist selbst gebastelt.
Da hat sich aber seit zwei Jahren nix mehr dran geändert.
Ich geh jetzt auf, Leute.
Mick, Diät, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wir sehen uns bis denn.
CU, ich hab Hunger.
Peppofat.
issautoutoutoutoutoutoutout失